This is Jocko podcast number 102 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
And we are rolling into some Q and a from the interwebs.
Sure.
So let's go right to it.
Jocko.
Is there ever a good time to use an ultimatum?
That's a great question.
And I think the answer's actually,
I think what everyone thinks about the answer,
I think it's pretty
self evident and I think a lot of people will agree with it.
Okay.
So is there ever a good time to use an ultimatum?
I think sometimes there is,
but it's seldom.
It's actually very seldom.
But when enough is truly enough,
then you've got to draw the line and you've got to hold the line,
right?
So you've got to make an ultimatum.
Uh,
one thing that is extremely critical is that you should never make an ultimatum
that you won't or can't keep right off the blow off if you say it.
Do it.
And what's interesting from a job perspective,
so like in the workplace perspective,
let's say up the chain of command up the chain of command,
it's not good.
Right?
So,
so let's say you're my boss and I come in and say,
Echo,
I want to raise,
I want to buy this Friday or I'm Outta here,
right?
That's an ultimatum.
And that means I'm trying to hold you hostage.
Most people do not like being held hostage.
So my chances of actually supporting what you're trying to make happen are very
small because I'm actually mad at you.
I don't want to support you.
Ooh,
you're a big critical guy.
Cause you press record and you made some videos for me.
You know what I mean?
Like it's like that.
But you're throwing an ultimatum at me.
That's where we're at.
We couldn't have a conversation.
We couldn't come to an agreement.
So you're going to walk into me.
I'm the boss.
I just reversed roles.
You're walking to me.
I'm the boss.
So you're going to say Jocko,
I wore raise and I want it now or I am out of here on Friday.
That's my ultimatum.
What?
What are you doing it right?
Are you building a relationship with me?
No.
Are you giving any room to negotiate or money?
Are you giving yourself any room to maneuver?
No.
No,
you're not.
You're not giving yourself any room to maneuver.
So that one generally doesn't work very well.
Now.
Now if you have another job offer that someone has put in front of you that's
legit and it's good and it's solid,
and,
and you come in to me and say,
Hey Jocko,
I got another job offer.
They want an answer by Friday,
here's what they're going to pay me.
I'm not,
this isn't a threat.
I'm not trying to be a jerk.
I'm being straight up with you.
But if you don't give me what I want by Friday,
I'm going to have to leave and go cause I gotta I gotta improve my future.
And I'd say,
hey man,
that sounds like a great deal of working for them.
Go
Right?
But that,
so that's,
that's an ultimatum.
But it's a rational one,
right?
Because you actually have a backup and you actually are trying to be
straightforward with me.
Yeah.
So,
so that's an ultimatum.
But it's,
it's like a logical one now down the chain of command,
people don't like it.
Ultimatums either.
For instance,
you know,
uh,
Echo,
if you don't have this project done by Friday,
you're fired.
So now I put a big ultimatum on you and you don't like that anymore than the
Boston people don't like having ultimatums put on them.
So what really do if you have to use ultimatums down the chain of command,
and you should check your leadership real real quick because you've made some
mistakes,
right?
People don't understand the deadlines.
People don't understand what it is you want them to do.
People don't understand why they're doing what they're doing.
There's all kinds of things that they don't understand.
If you have to start throwing ultimatums around as a boss.
Yeah,
so really if you find yourself using ultimatums,
then you need to check your leadership.
Now,
that being said,
if you,
if I've talked to you,
if I've coached you,
if I've counseled you,
if I've done a written statement on you and told you exactly what it is I need
echo to do and now we've,
we've passed the point of no return.
I go,
okay,
Echo.
Here's what I asked you to do.
You didn't do it.
This is the ultimatum.
If you don't start making three videos a week,
you are not going to be here anymore.
And you'd say,
you'd either say,
okay,
well I'm going to do it,
or screw Jocko,
he's a jerk,
I'm outta here.
And either way,
W I've moved forward because you weren't doing it before.
And that's sort,
I know that that example is,
you know,
of hits close to home.
So ultimatums be very,
very careful.
Make sure if you're going to use it,
it's gotta be real.
You've got to enforce it and check yourself.
Don't,
don't,
don't get yourself in a position where you can't maneuver anymore.
That's the biggest that to me,
that's the biggest point.
You never want to take away your ability to move,
maneuver.
You don't want to do that.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
And it,
or it feels like,
you know,
just how you kind of said it to me.
Well that first one where the tone has like a lot to do with it.
Yeah.
Like how you were like,
you know,
you're legitimate,
logical ultimately.
Right.
It seemed like it wasn't like the first one leave.
We'll look,
give me this or I'm outta here kind of thing.
And then the second year,
second example,
it's sort of like,
hey,
you know,
see what's going on.
And yeah,
it feels like if someone did that to me either way up or down,
I feel like it would still maintain the relationship,
you know,
like let's say let's say it worked out and it was like,
okay,
you know,
whatever you got the raise or whatever.
And if you sit in that crazy tone or whatever,
when that real fed up tone,
you're still like,
okay,
cool.
We,
we worked it out,
I got what I want,
but,
um,
but we know,
dinged the relationship,
it's deemed and we don't want to be digging or relationships.
We want to be building those things.
And I think a lot of times people,
like they'll ding the relationship and then they'll just move on like nothing.
But meanwhile the other person's like,
Hey,
don't forget what you said to me and how you said that last week.
Time heals the wounds,
but it doesn't remove the scars.
Yeah,
yeah.
By the way.
Slapshot okay.
All alright.
Next question.
Graduated high school,
crushed it.
Straight A's,
boom.
Help my classmates with kindness kind and helpful and expected them to be.
Meanwhile,
they put me down,
mocked me,
never loved me in a room with 30 people.
I was always alone.
Inner voice tells me to go after the past.
Seek revenge.
Keep looking at their profiles.
Profiles,
like online profiles on social media.
Yeah.
Should I go now?
He's got a series of questions here.
Should I go after them and try to fix the past,
either by revenge or else should I,
should I remove them from social media and leave the Facebook group?
Should I attend the reunion?
Why have they even been in my life?
Okay,
so let's break those down.
Number one,
should I go after them and try to fix the past either by revenge or something
else to answer that,
in my opinion is no man,
who cares?
They're high school kids.
Move on.
Get on with your life.
Disagree.
Agree,
agree.
Okay.
That one's me is pretty straight forward.
Don't worry about these Germans.
I actually had a couple conversations with,
with uh,
my oldest daughters haven't had this one with my son yet,
but my older daughters,
which is,
hey look,
these people that are around right now that you think are so important in high
school,
they're not,
you know,
some of them might be,
you might have some lifelong friends from high school.
I get that.
But these people that are not nice to you,
you won't be thinking about them.
So I don't,
I'm not sure how old this individual is,
but she's got a couple more years before he won't be thinking about these people
anymore.
So just get there earlier question too.
Should I remove them from social media and leave this Facebook group?
Okay.
This is a little bit tricky in my opinion.
Uh,
first of all,
if you can,
if you can stay,
if you can keep them on social media,
but ignore them completely,
just leave me alone.
Just leave it and just totally ignore them because when you leave them or
whatever,
you're kind of,
aren't you kind of making a scene?
I just want to make sure.
Do you want to make a scene?
Well,
yeah,
like when you unfriend them or whatever,
which it didn't.
You and I have some situation with the we did.
Yeah,
actually.
Okay,
so
I know that I,
wait,
who unfriended you?
My wife.
Yup.
Okay,
so you did it well,
no,
no.
I didn't even know how to do it.
Now you figured it out?
No,
I didn't.
So I didn't ever have social media until two years ago,
but all of a sudden I saw echo friends with my wife and I said,
well wait,
wait.
She's showing me something.
And she says,
and I see echo.
And I said,
well why are you friends with people that,
why are you friends with people that I know a or click on the friend on that?
And I didn't even know it was a big deal.
I just thought,
you know,
hey,
that means,
and,
and then I didn't realize a big deal.
It's a big deal,
man.
Unfriended him messed up.
I thought you did it per purposefully knowing it's a big deal,
but not understanding that it's even a bigger deal than you know.
Okay.
Where you're like unfriend him as a joke.
That was like,
it was totally your personality at that thought.
I did that to you.
Yeah.
Like as a joke,
like I'm afraid them,
you don't say something to me like immediately or was it,
did it did a month go by where I didn't make a joke about it.
I forget.
So,
so it is kind of making a scene.
If you,
if you unfriend this person or you leave the group,
then you're just creating a little firestorm.
But I will say this,
if you can't,
if you can't keep yourself from checking on them,
then you might have to do that.
So try it for a couple of weeks just so I'm not looking at them.
Yeah,
let them go.
Just leave him.
Yeah.
If you can't do that,
then delete them and leave the group or whatever.
So the number three,
should I attend the reunion?
My answer to that is negative.
Don't.
Why would you?
These people are negative.
They have,
they bring back negative memories.
They didn't treat you well,
they,
but why would you?
You don't need to move on again.
Key Word I think.
Move on.
Yeah.
And then the last question is why have they even been in my life?
Well,
I think just like anything else bad that happens in life,
the things that are bad that happened in life
can either teach you or break you and you got to decide what you want them to
do.
I vote that you,
you allow it to teach you.
I,
I vote.
Did you learn from these people that you learn how to forget about the past?
That you learn how to ignore people that are negative,
that you learn to control your vengeful ideas and that you learn to move on into
the future where you're going to meet better people and better times are to be
had.
That's what I would recommend.
Don't worry about these people from the past.
They're caught up in this weird world.
Yeah.
High School.
This is high school,
right?
There were caught up in high school world or worried about high school.
Get into the world.
Yeah.
Right.
Big Time.
Well,
I've had one daughter that now graduated from high school.
I got two kids in high right now.
Yeah.
Drama.
There's drama,
but actually believe it or not,
there hasn't been a lot of drama with my kids.
Not a lot of high school drama.
That doesn't surprise me,
but,
but I see it,
it does happen.
And I remember the drama.
I'd say my guess,
I don't know.
It's been a long time since high school for me personally.
But yeah,
man,
I think that's life.
You know,
high school is drama.
A bunch of kids not knowing nothing.
Is there more drama in high school than there is in life?
Maybe it's because it's stuck together.
Yeah,
it seems like a,
you're stuck there.
It depends on your life.
Like if you just consider it a typical high school versus my life.
Yeah.
Way More in high school drama and my I in your drama,
that's it.
And you're not even really that job.
Really.
Yeah.
They're all high school.
Although even this guy obviously,
you know,
so it's gonna feel like way more than it is for sure.
But you know,
when you,
when you the,
the further you go along in life,
the more you realize that this means less and less,
these types of things anyway,
when you consider it high school was really just for learning.
Sure.
You learn things too.
You know what I just thought of is what's interesting about this is if you're
looking back on high school,
either with fond memories or with negative memories that way,
it's not a great thing because you could be like uncle Rico from Napoleon
dynamite.
Right.
Just constantly living back his high school football games and he's wishing he
made that pass and you know what I mean?
One the state championship or whatever.
Yeah.
You get to,
that's not good.
Right.
That means you're stuck in high school.
You peaked in high school.
Yeah.
If you're looking back at the negative things,
same thing.
Yes and no move forward.
Yeah.
In his defense though,
obviously he just graduated.
That's what life really is.
This really,
you know,
it's still new.
It's like,
you know,
someone more good stuff's going to happen,
brother.
You just move on and get after it.
Yeah.
Probably the social media thing.
Now I'll say this cause there's,
there's little levels of like unfriending what are,
you can unfollow someone.
I'm assuming this is Facebook.
I don't know.
There's so many.
He could be talking about other stuff,
but on Facebook you can still remain,
remain friends,
but just unfollow them so you won't get all their stuff.
Do they know that?
I don't think so.
I'm sure many people have unfollowed me and I don't know that I've never gotten
in the alert or whatever.
Um,
I would say leave the group fully.
Oh,
I always listen to your advice more than me because I don't understand it as
much as you do.
I,
I don't,
I don't understand the Facebook group thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
depends how many people are going to make a scene.
I don't like to make a scene.
Yeah.
So I'd be like,
well no,
I'm just gonna ignore it.
Yeah.
I don't think leaving the group as a scene if it is,
I mean obviously it depends on how many people in the group is less people in
the group.
Don't worry of a scene it's going to be,
or if he's always posting,
if he's the head of the group or something like this,
then yeah.
You know how in the past there was etiquette schools I went to,
I went to etiquette classes when I went to officer candidate school in
Pensacola,
Florida.
And they teach you which knife to use,
all that stuff,
and they teach you things.
For instance,
you might not know this.
If you take a bite of food and there's something in that bite of food that you
don't want to eat a bone of,
whatever.
The way to properly get it out of your mouth is to use your fork,
put it on the fork and put it back down on the plate.
So like,
yeah.
Okay,
Gotcha.
They would say the same.
So that's the type of thing.
There should be a class
or we're going to a point where people are gonna need a class on social media
etiquette.
Actually,
that's not a bad idea.
You should teach it.
All right,
let's move on.
I sorry.
Yeah,
the high school.
Move on.
Move on,
brother.
Move on.
Let's move on from that question.
There it is.
We don't,
you know,
that's like,
that's,
we focused on social media,
but that's just about everything,
right?
Anything that you're caught up in,
anything that you're caught up in.
Yeah.
That's dragging you down.
Just move on.
Whether it's a girl,
whether it's the job you should have had,
whether it's the investment you should have made,
whether it's the,
the house you didn't buy that you should have all those things move on man.
It's gone.
Move on.
Yeah,
it seems like high school is,
it's really common one,
you know,
like the old classic story of the person who got bullied in high school and then
going back to the finish [inaudible] you know,
like that kind of stuff.
But yeah,
the more,
and this is what it feels like to,
I don't know,
I'm not everyone,
but the more you do for yourself after high school,
for sure.
The last high school is going to mean for sure.
Like this isn't gonna end.
You know how they say Uncle Rico,
man,
he,
you sell in Tupperware and it wasn't working out good for him.
Yeah.
He high school is still a big deal to yeah.
You know guys who were like,
they always talk about high school football or whatever and there's guys like
that for sure.
Um,
then you can,
it's kind of an indicator,
you know,
that Oh,
he might not be doing much now,
so shit,
they're like 40 or something like that.
Check.
I next wish.
I'm thinking about starting Jujitsu in my MMA gym,
but the instructor is a brown belt.
Should I go train with him or look for a black belt
for,
well,
if you're at an MMA gym,
they have brown belt.
That's awesome.
God turned with a brown belt.
I think he's probably really,
really good.
I think it's probably fight oriented because it's in a fight to fight gym,
which is good in my opinion.
And you know,
the fact of matter is,
and we've said this before,
Brown belt,
purple belt,
black belt,
there's good teachers in all of those blue belt,
you know,
borderline.
Really,
you can learn some good fundamentals from work.
Solid blue belt though.
I agree.
But,
um,
and also there's some black belts that are not good teachers and there's some
purple belts that are phenomenal teachers.
So yeah.
Gautrain yeah,
I think that's pretty simple question.
Yup.
Yeah.
The
DPA,
you know how you just said like some,
some purple belts are great teachers.
So the,
the belt usually for the most part just indicates the vast,
like the knowledge,
you know,
so it's given that they're a good teacher.
So yeah,
if it's a brown belt shoot,
that's a lot of knowledge and just given that he's all right or better teacher
that's going to be legit.
And there is actually blue belts as well,
said that there's some blue belts that are really good teachers.
Yeah.
Although it does,
you know,
you get a purple belt teacher,
whereas the blue belt teacher and they're good teachers,
both of them.
Of course you're gonna want the party cause he's going to have more knowledge.
You so you know,
blue belt,
in most cases it is in most cases,
cases.
Yeah.
But if you're just starting your own,
you can pray.
You're just going to be like a sponge.
If someone you don't even know what you,
you know what's interesting,
you could probably barely tell.
If you're a white belt and you roll with the purple belt and a black belt,
you wouldn't be able to delegate.
Yes.
All you know is you got your ass whooped.
That's what you know.
That's all you know.
You don't know how easy it was for them because this is the same level for both.
Neither one of those people's try and hard against white belt.
Yeah.
And yeah,
and if they know how to teach,
like I said,
he's an instructor.
He's the instructor brown belt.
Yeah.
He's going to be fine.
In fact,
that's way more common than you think.
I mean,
we're in San Diego,
even in San Diego though.
There's a brown belt instructors for sure.
And they're good too.
Yeah.
And especially if you're just starting.
Yeah,
man.
Good.
Do that.
And Yeah,
just like how you said though,
sometimes the black belt instructor,
he'll be good at rolling,
he'll be good at Jujitsu and he can win tournaments when he can't really
instruct that good or they or you get like situations where,
I mean I wouldn't say it's super common but it's there for sure is,
you know,
you heard the expression [inaudible] knowledge,
right?
It's like you've been a black belt for so long or anything right.
It just so good at something that you forget what it's like to be a beginner.
So you Kinda,
you know,
you might skip over some details that are kind of critical if you're a beginner,
you just kind of,
your subconscious just assumes that this person knows a certain amount of
things.
You know,
you can get that like that's I think a lot of times what gems are.
But really advanced teachers watching Andy and Noah role,
we are doing some rounds of Andy and Noah tucked his foot underneath the far arm
on an arm walk from across like cross side,
like a regular arm lock.
And Noah's talking his foot under there and dean says,
know,
hey,
that's a really good detail to who taught you that.
And I was like,
I taught him and he was like,
I taught him and nobody that,
that's something that Dean taught me.
And I don't know who taught.
No,
but it's just,
that's the type of detail that you're talking about where that is a small thing.
You gotta be in Jujitsu for it.
You got to get a lot of other things right before someone says when your arm
walking,
someone on the far side,
put your,
put your toes basically underneath their arm to secure their shoulder a little
bit better.
That's deep.
There's so there's those kinds of details.
There was another thing where I had a,
uh,
a finish for Dean or dean was teaching me an arm lock finish and I would try it
and I was trying and we're trying,
I would try it and it would never work.
I tried it on him 50 times and finally one day he says,
Hey,
when you do that move,
put the pressure here instead of here.
The next time.
I did it to him worked.
Do you know what I mean?
And then one little detail
it.
Same thing happened the other day with Andy.
I was going with Andy and we were doing the arm lock escapes and he said,
Hey,
you're putting your pressure here.
He showed me where I was putting the pressure.
He said put it here and I was like,
hmm,
next time I did it to him he's like,
that hurts so bad.
So it's weird.
It's the little details that again,
the better the instructor is the the more detailed too you're going to get and
most,
well,
what's important about this is until you are,
get to a certain level you,
those details don't even mean anything to you because you,
you can't worry about where you're putting some little detail on an arm lock
when you don't even know how to do the Armagnac and that'd be pretty damn good
at the arm lock before you started looking at the little tiny details and then
they,
and that's it.
That was actually going to be part of the point where you get a black belt,
super advanced level instructor.
But he's not necessarily that good at being a teacher.
He'll start teaching those details and all stuff.
Whoa.
You just skipped over the part to teach them how to do the actual Armbar,
but he's like kind of subconsciously there'll be like heal the crystal of
knowledge says that.
It's kind of just assumed this is,
and this is good for the Jujitsu journey.
I used to say this when,
when I'm teaching you a Jujitsu move,
let's say there's 10 things that you have to do to make the Jujitsu move work.
I can teach you five of them.
The other five you have to figure out because it's where you're putting your
weight and it's where you're putting your balance.
Dean might be able to teach you seven
maybe.
Maybe if you take a different class,
Andy,
we'll teach you an eight to one,
but there's things that you have to figure out on your own on top of the things
that you can be shown.
Yeah.
That's why you got a roll.
Big Time.
You got a role because that's the only way you figure out if it actually works
or not and what little adjustments you have to make.
Yeah,
yeah,
fully.
And especially if you have a good instructor,
they can see it too.
You know,
like you know when you drill something or when you're doing the technique just
with your partner and stuff,
you're like,
okay,
yeah,
good.
That's good technique and no one will like us moving and trying to defend or
whatever.
It's like I don't know what I'm doing wrong.
It's not working.
And really the obvious answer is yeah,
because he's not letting you do it,
but you know,
someone like an instructor can look and see like,
oh,
you're letting him do
this or what or whatever you're forgetting to do this check.
But nonetheless,
yeah,
I agree with you.
Go train with the brown belt guy,
see how it go train.
Yeah.
But if you're not learning nothing,
then you can make that evaluation.
But the fact that he's a brown belt,
you'll be learning a ton.
It'd be learning a ton given that for sure.
Next question.
You talk about playing the game,
quote unquote to win,
but what about people that play the game to win for themselves and how do I
defeat them?
That's a good,
good question and it,
it hit me when I saw that question.
I was like,
Ooh,
that's a good
point.
And that's a good,
there's a very important distinction there because I'm always saying play the
game right here.
You got to play the game,
you got to,
you got to build the relationships with the boss and you got to learn what they
like and you got to toe the party line.
You kind of do the little things.
You got to support the corporate headquarters or the boss or the man,
right?
Or whatever entity is up in that ivory tower.
I want you to play the game,
get them on your side.
And the reason I saved to do those things is that so you can get more control so
that people ask your opinion so that you get listened to so that perhaps you get
promoted,
which is good.
But the reason you're doing all those things,
the reason that you're playing the game is to help your team accomplished the
mission.
That's what you are trying to do.
It's to help your team accomplish the mission.
Now the,
the other side of that is what this question is about.
People that are playing the game for personal gain,
they,
they play the games that they can get listened to so they can drive their
personal agenda.
So they so vague can get promoted and they want to get promoted so that they can
abuse their power.
And maybe that abuse of power is just,
is just working less.
Maybe it's making other people do the crap jobs,
whatever the,
whatever the case may be.
But they've got an agenda and they're going to try and get promoted so they can
take care of themselves.
And that is not why I tell you to play the game.
And that's not why I played the game and I definitely played the game and I
played to win,
but I played because I wanted my my squad or my platoon or my task unit or my
training command to be able to better accomplish our mission.
That's what I played the game.
Now.
Well there is a secondary benefit of playing the game and that is that you could
possibly get promoted earlier.
You could get praise from the boss that looks good on your record and,
and all those things can happen when you're playing the game.
But that's just like collateral sort of fringe benefits.
But that's not why you're playing the game.
You play the game to help the team win and when the team wins you win,
which also makes the team win again.
So it's like a positive cycle cause you start developing a good reputation.
Now you get more leeway from the Boston,
have more leeway you get from the boss.
The more you have the ability to make maneuvers on the battlefield,
but more you can maneuver on the battlefield,
the more offensive you can be,
the more you win,
and then you get more ability to move more because your boss is giving you even
more room to maneuver.
So it's a,
it's a cycle.
It's a good positive cycle.
Now when you have someone that's on the team that's playing the game for
themselves,
first of all,
no one likes that person,
right?
Everyone can see that person.
Yeah.
No one likes them and there's,
believe me,
the military,
the military has unbelievable people that play the game for the best possible
reasons to help their platoon and help the mission to help succeed.
There's also plenty of people in the military and in every,
every different line of work.
There's plenty of people that play the game because they want to,
they want them.
They want to look out for themselves.
Looking out for number one right?
Isn't that the expression they're looking out for?
Number one,
there's plenty of people.
And I dealt with people like that all the time.
And what did I do?
Okay.
I used it to my advantage and I'll tell you what I would get in their head.
And what I would do is I would make them think that the best way for them to win
for themselves personally was for the team to win.
That I would get that into their head cause let's talk.
A lot of times they missed that point.
They're looking out for themselves,
they're not worried about the team.
And I would get them thinking that they're going to look the best if the team
wins.
Hey,
if you really want to look good,
the best way you can get promoted as if we look good.
You know,
if there's a team does great.
If you get us the gear,
we want the equipment,
we want their training that we need,
that's the best way you're going to look awesome cause we're going to succeed
more than that's going to make you look good.
And I'm,
of course I'm going to be more tactful and I'm not saying it like that,
but I'm saying it right.
Right.
Getting them to get the messaging.
Is there going to be saying,
hey,
you know,
our boss doesn't like our boss doesn't like leaders that complain.
Right.
You know a kid,
you can tell the boss,
he doesn't like complainers,
you know what I mean?
Little blue things like that,
right?
Yeah.
Hey,
the boss,
the boss likes to hear the truth about stuff he wants to know.
You know what I mean?
Little things like that.
And you know what?
Here's the thing,
that person,
that person might get the promotion.
Okay.
Because what you've done is you've helped them act correctly actually,
and there's a chance,
a decent chance,
a good chance even that they carry that forward.
They realize that,
hey,
the best way to play the game is to help the team.
And the best way to look good is to help,
is to make the team good and succeed at the mission.
Hmm.
And it's really,
well,
you know,
one of the classic cases,
then we'll know we'll,
we'll get into ownership a little,
but if something goes wrong,
right,
the person that's looking out for themselves blames everyone else.
And so that's a challenge,
right?
Because once you start blaming,
once that ball starts blaming everyone,
then the whole team starts blaming each other.
So how do you fix that?
Well it's,
we've talked about this a million times.
You step up and say,
hey,
you know what boss is my fault and loss.
Cause that's right.
It's your fault.
And there's a,
there's a good chance that they recognize how positive that is.
And it may take a while and it may never happen because some people are just
savages,
right?
Some people are just complete.
They only care about themselves.
They only care about the next promotion and getting the next award and getting
the next bit of recognition.
There's people like that,
there's the,
they're horrible,
they exist.
But they're pretty small.
Most people,
if they see,
hey this,
this is working for this guy,
it can work for me too.
And that starts to spread.
And the other thing that happens,
I think is if someone's just a flagrant self promoter,
that you might get them one promotion because you were there to kind of make
them look good,
but the next time around they're going to get seen.
They're going to get found out.
They're gonna.
People are gonna realize what kind of person they are and that's,
that's where it catches up with them.
So you keep playing the game,
you keep,
you keep working hard,
don't worry about them and actually do your best to help them out.
The person that's like self promoting,
do your best to help them out.
They're the boss.
Make them look good.
Oh,
how was wanting to make my boss look good?
Yup.
It's going to help you in the long run.
It can hurt sometimes.
It's hard to do.
Sometimes our ego gets in the way.
Sometimes you got to put that ego in check because what's more important?
Because if you're my boss Echo and you're doing this just to make yourself look
good,
if I then undermine you will,
and now we don't accomplish the mission as well.
I'm actually a bad person because I didn't do my best to accomplish the mission.
We didn't look good.
I'm not worried about how we look,
but we failed in our mission and we didn't do our mission to the best of our
ability.
So No,
I'm not gonna let that happen.
You want to look great.
Cool.
I want to make you look great because I want us to look great doing our mission
because that's what's important to me.
And it's so some of the collateral damage of that is that you look great even
though you're a jerk and I get you promoted,
that's okay because eventually you're going to get found out or you're going to
learn to be a better person and to support the team and that's how you got
promoted and you're gonna realize that and you'll become a good leader.
Yeah,
I agree with that one.
Like I always have where people can see that too.
You know,
they can see,
you know,
like if your boss is like a self promoter or whatever and you have it in your
head.
I understand.
I understand this because I've been in a situation
where I'm like,
shoot,
I kind of feel inside like I don't want to like make an effort to make them look
good kind of thing.
Cause it's like he doesn't deserve it and the thing and what like what,
I'm going to make them look good and now everyone's going to think that he looks
good kind of thing.
But then when you really think about it another not,
yeah,
you're right.
And the same goes though for you.
Like if you,
if you're like,
you know,
if you're just focusing on the positive stuff,
you know and you know how like your shit,
if you don't have anything nice to say,
don't say it at all.
If you're really doing that,
like people notice that too.
I was like man that guy is like really positive focusing on this,
you know,
kind of thing.
Like people see it and this doesn't mean you're just Mr positive sugar coat and
everything.
No it's not.
We're not talking about that.
But you are not focusing on the negative.
Instead of saying,
oh we're horrible at this.
You said,
you know what,
we've got some deficiencies here.
Here's what I'm gonna do to fix them.
Yeah.
How simple is that?
Just get better.
The point is people they see,
they see,
don't think that,
you know,
like you're going to help,
make this guy look good in.
They're just gonna.
They're going to not see it and they're just going to fall for that.
He is trick or something bad.
They see that most of the time.
Most of the time.
That example that you said about Tim,
uh,
playing to their ego or whatever,
where you're like,
hey,
you're going to look really good if we were dumping.
So you ever seen the movie Milana?
I saw three minutes on it.
Oh,
see,
there you go.
She does.
Uh,
so the guy,
the main guy,
his name,
the Demi God,
his name is Molly and played by the Rock,
by the way.
20 Johnson.
Great movie by the way.
Um,
she does him like that.
She's like,
Hey,
let's,
they got to go do this mission,
you know,
for restore the heart,
whatever.
It's a long story,
but,
and he's like,
you know,
whatever reluctant.
And he's like,
she's like,
hey,
you'll be a hero again.
And he's like,
I'm already a hero.
She was like,
well go for a while.
You know,
you haven't done anything lately,
but if you do this and you'll be the hero to everyone.
And Yeah,
and of course he does it of course.
But yeah,
man,
it's good to get a quick example.
It works there it is.
Proof on Amada
trash.
I have to say that in a very competitive environment,
extreme ownership can be used by your enemies
or the people that want your position.
When you take ownership over all faults of your team members,
you guys become,
you guys become better and get healthier,
a healthier attitude.
But that takes time.
So until your team improves and start to get better results,
your opponents will take those tens of it was my fault.
And present them to your boss as proof that,
yeah,
this guy is not good or at least not confident enough and looks weak is not my
case.
For me,
it worked great,
but I've seen it happening too.
Few colleagues who just didn't have good team members
and they took their extreme ownership for weakness and just took advantage of
that.
Okay.
So what we've got here is what he's saying is extreme ownership.
If you're taking extreme ownership of things,
your enemies can actually take advantage of that.
And in this guy's case,
right?
Like in the like in the earlier stages of it.
Yeah.
And he said,
well actually he says that for him it's worked great,
but that he's seen some of his compadres who have started to take ownership and
they're,
they've got weak team and the team,
what does he say here?
What's the words he uses?
They didn't have good team members and they took their extreme ownership for
weakness and took advantage of it.
Okay.
So first of all,
out of the gate,
if you have weak or bad team members,
that is the first thing the leader needs to take ownership of.
Right.
If you have truly weak and bad team members,
then you need to either train them or coach them or get rid of them.
Okay.
That's the first thing.
So if you've got backstabbing,
bad team members that are looking to call you down as the leader,
you got a problem with those people and you need to fix that problem number one.
So let's just start with that.
Number two,
and this is,
this is there's two,
two kind of parts of this.
There's an insecurity,
a level of insecurity,
and there's a level of,
or a,
uh,
a matter of perception.
The insecurity is the thing that says,
if I say this is my fault and everyone up and down,
the chain of command is going to say,
fire him,
fire him.
It's his fault.
But I want you to think about how that's actually perceived.
If what you do is,
let's take the other example is what you do is you blame everyone else.
If that's your attitude,
if your attitude is,
it wasn't my fault,
it was his fault,
it was her fault.
It was their fault.
It was not me.
I'm just the person in charge is not me.
Think about that statement.
It's not my fault.
It's,
it's my team's fault.
I'm just the person in charge.
It's not my fault.
Think about that.
Whenever you're placing blame,
if your leader and your placing blame on your team,
okay,
what you're saying is,
hey,
it's not my fault.
It's my team's fault.
I'm just the leader here.
I'm not the one out there in the field doing the work.
I'm not the one that's making those decisions.
I'm not the one that's,
you know,
uh,
interacting with customers.
I'm not the one that's doing that.
So this isn't my fault.
It's my team's fault.
Well,
meanwhile,
guess who's in charge of the team?
You are.
So the minute that you start saying it wasn't my fault in his swirly,
everyone else's fault did that.
If you think about how you look to your boss,
it's laughable.
You look like an idiot,
okay?
You don't look like a good leader.
So don't fall for,
and you know what?
I'm actually not saying that you'll never get fired if you take ownership
because you only,
if you do something that's really bad,
there's absolutely a chance you'd get fired.
If you do something that costs a bunch of money or was immoral or illegal,
or you covered something up and,
or your team covered something up,
or you did something that was truly wrong and you take ownership of it,
yeah,
use might still get fired.
You know what that happens in the navy and the navy.
If your ship runs aground or like lately there's been some collisions on the
ships and all that.
I think Lafe and I might talk about those at some point on the podcast,
but the captain of the ship is done.
It doesn't matter if he was on the ship or not.
Hmm.
He could be because just because the ships at sea,
the captain might have had to flown to another ship to talk to the admiral.
If his ship crashes,
he's done.
It doesn't matter if he's there or not.
He's responsible for the training.
He's responsible for the actions.
He's responsible for everything that's happened on that ship.
And he's getting fired.
And He,
and,
and also if he did do something wrong,
well,
yeah,
he's,
and he takes ownership of it doesn't matter.
He's getting fired.
So I'm not saying you're never gonna get fired.
Um,
but generally,
generally,
and this is when I say generally this is the vast majority of the time,
this is 99% of the time.
If you take ownership,
you don't look like a weak boss.
You look like a strong boss that is taking ownership of problems that is going
to get the problem solved.
I say this over and over again.
[inaudible]
Andy
as always,
you don't just have to own the problems.
You have to own the solutions to the problems too.
So
this is the situation here.
We got this guy,
people,
if you're in charge of a bad team and you're taking ownership,
the bad team is what you have to fix.
You have to fix it.
You have to train them,
you have to curve,
you have to coach them,
you have to mentor them.
You have to do all those things.
And if you can't get them to get on board with the program,
then you've got to get rid of them or get rid of that one or two bad people that
are causing the infraction and causing that cancer to spread.
Get rid of them.
Set the example.
Promote somebody that's hungry and young and wants to get after it.
Hmm.
So you got to take ownership of the team,
the problems,
the weak people on the team.
You got to take ownership of the solutions and get them solved it seems like,
and it kind of notices from the beginning go that when you take,
he was going to cut you off with,
I have to talk about this before.
Sometimes people say they think if they say,
I'll take ownership of this,
then the problems,
then it's like there had been,
they're safe.
That's exactly what you're saying.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That is not the case.
Just because you say,
Hey,
this is my fault.
It's my fault.
I'm taking ownership with this.
That doesn't mean the problem's solved.
There's a problem.
Yeah.
You have to say,
yes,
there's a problem here.
I'm taking ownership of,
it's my fault because I'm in charge and this is what we're going to do to fix
it.
And then you have to actually go and fix it.
There's the part right
there.
Yeah,
that scene.
Because if you come to meet 12 times and you say,
hey Jo Koy we didn't get the podcast out cause I forgot to hit record.
Hey that's my boss.
That's my boss.
Okay,
well hey from now on,
here's when we're do,
I'm going to make sure that we have this things in place and I hooked up the
light and it's gonna if,
if the thing isn't recording the,
the studio is going to go dark.
I Dunno if you remember this because this might be just the way you are,
but when we went to remember
where do we go?
We went like last trip we went on driving,
we went to,
oh Charlie plumb.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure it's really hard.
And we were looking for,
I can't remember what we were looking for either the hotel or the place or
wherever.
A house.
That was a good,
so we're going and I was kind of navigating and you were kind of navigating,
kind of trying to help,
not trying to help,
but you were kind of navigating but kind of nuts.
It really seemed like to me anyway,
you were like,
okay,
I'll let you kind of navigate and we uh,
we took a wrong turn,
whatever,
you know,
we're off track or whatever.
And
I was like,
okay,
I got to take extreme ownership right now.
Cause it's like right now it's like the perfect time to take action on it or it
should I say the worst time not to take a chain monitor.
Right.
So I'm like,
oh no,
that's my bad.
Like I'm gonna,
you know,
I'm going to do this kind of thing.
But at the same time you like really aggressively took ownership.
Like you're almost to the point where at,
at first I was like,
are you joking?
But you weren't joking.
You were like,
take,
take the next turn right here and then we'd come close to it.
You'd be like this turn right here.
Turn around acute at all around.
You were not letting me,
you know,
make a mistake again,
but,
which is funny though,
but it is a good example because not only,
I mean in your mind you,
you put forward the more important part.
You were like,
okay,
I'm going to take,
it's like your actions said that it's your fault,
but you're the solutions that that you had even though they're really extreme or
whatever.
Like that was the part that you were imposing a jerk about it though was,
I don't know,
just,
okay.
All right.
Do you know what?
Here's the deal.
Next term's going to be 0.5 miles.
Here's coming up on the right.
All right.
Right hand turn right here.
That's how,
that's how we navigate in the,
it's actually good.
I mean,
it's really squared away.
Yeah.
You're in a convoy of military vehicles.
It's awesome.
And you know,
it's bad.
It's really on.
My part is that at first I thought you're joking,
like patronizing me,
you know?
No,
I'm don't do that.
But that's really kind of my ego.
You know,
as if this say like Duh.
I,
you said the next turn this the next to her and I can figure that out.
You know,
I'm smart enough to figure that out kind of thing.
But if I'm like,
okay,
this is the system and you know,
Jack was going to,
you know,
tell me and he's going to be detailed about it and make absolutely sure we don't
miss the turn kind of thing,
then you're right.
Dang,
that's a good way to navigate,
you know,
but two people
got to be on board,
but none the less like,
Dang,
you had the solution,
you know.
So it goes back to it like it seems like back to this question,
um,
your enemies could take advantage early on,
right.
As it's,
as the extreme ownership culture is trying to take hold kind of is what it kind
of get from it.
Um,
like even early on,
that's what I think
even early on you don't look like an idiot.
You actually look squared away because you go,
here are the problems that we're having that I've identified.
Here's what we're going to do to fix them.
Yeah.
No one knows where we're driving right now.
You're kind of half driving and half paying attention.
I'm over here talking or doing whatever.
Guess what?
We made a mistake.
It's not going to happen again.
I got this.
Hey,
yeah,
right.
Turn coming up 500 meters,
right turn getting the left hand lane,
prepare to go.
You know what I mean?
That's what,
that's how we solved the problem and to think in the beginning,
you know,
you get there and you say,
hey,
here's the problem.
Here's what we're going to fix it.
It's not,
hey,
everything's my fault.
That's not extra.
Every extreme ownership isn't,
hey,
everything's my fault.
Everything's my fault
and how can you just leave me alone?
No,
especially not in that actually have to take ownership of the problems.
Said that over and over again,
but hey,
you know what?
Just like Jujitsu,
you got to see a move a bunch of different times,
a bunch of different ways.
Yeah.
Bunch of different ways before you start to truly understand it.
Think that's everything.
Do you ever,
do you ever hear yourself make an excuse?
No.
I knew him or not anymore.
I know like,
you know,
like how you say you like you can feel it
coming out,
excuses coming a mile away.
And here's the thing,
you have them in your head,
excuse,
complaining,
um,
uh,
complain about like how you feel,
you know,
like when there's something to be done.
I'm not saying,
you know,
in every single case,
but when there's something to be done and be like,
I'm tired of doing this or I don't know,
whatever.
That was just a random example.
But man,
I can see that stuff coming a mile away.
Yeah,
it's definitely something that you get used to and you get good at.
Right.
You get good at,
you're good at saying,
you get good at not saying,
well,
you know,
one of my assistant platoon commanders,
who's an awesome guy,
and he had this thing,
if he was going to disagree with me,
he would say the word well meaning,
you know,
well let's think about it.
But he had a funny way of saying it.
He would say,
Whoa,
like that.
And so I'd say,
Hey,
we,
you know,
how you going to do this?
And he'd come up with his plan and,
and I'd say,
Hey,
what about this on the plan?
You will,
you might want to come in from the north and said from the West.
And he'd go,
well,
and then I'd say after a while that became a code word for you're about to get
chills.
But he's a total,
he's an awesome guy.
Check.
Well,
tell me yours next west
Jocko have had discipline equals freedom audio on repeat since its release.
And I love it.
Question,
if our greatest strength is our greatest weakness,
then how is discipline,
which is obviously your,
your strength,
your greatest weakness.
Uh,
first of all,
okay.
I don't even know what,
I don't know if discipline would be my greatest strength.
I don't know.
I mean,
I'm a disciplined person.
Yeah,
no doubt.
But I think it,
I think that,
okay.
I think that one of the things that people would find interesting is that
I'm not overly orderly
[inaudible].
So if you think about those like psychological characteristics,
one of them is extreme orderliness,
which normally goes hand in hand with highly disciplined to people.
None of those people that are,
um,
they're just old tra.
Highly disciplined,
but they have to have everything there.
They're OCD,
they're OCD orderly,
right?
Yeah.
And I,
I'm not like that about a lot of things.
I am about some things,
but like it's pretty funny actually.
My floor in my garage where I work out isn't,
is not clean.
Right?
It's got salt stains on it from sweat soft.
Oh yeah.
And it's dirty.
Right?
And occasionally we'll get someone say,
you should clean that floor or a man,
you screwed the poor man.
That's nasty.
But it totally functional.
Right.
And my point is that I don't,
I don't freak out about it.
It's functional.
It doesn't bother me at all.
That's not perfectly orderly.
This also means that I don't mind when things don't go as planned,
right?
So a lot of times you get people that are the high end of disciplined.
Yeah,
they're too,
they're too far.
They're not balanced.
So now when things don't go the way that they're,
that they've planned things to go,
the the,
they start to lose it a little bit.
They can't deal with it.
They want,
they want to have everything in order all the time.
And I'll tell you that's not the way life works.
That's certainly not the way combat works,
but that's not the way life works.
And I don't really mind that.
I don't mind chaos.
So I would say probably if,
if you look at discipline as a strength,
I don't think,
I think that would be generally considered the weaknesses of,
of being hyper disciplined is that you,
you can't stand when things are not going to order.
You can't stand like,
I missed a workout.
This is our,
they'll grow.
You freak out completely.
Like,
did you know,
okay,
I don't like missing a workout,
but I don't lose
my mind over it.
Yeah.
Now.
All that being said,
I would say that I am a very much a creature of habit and I do like to do the
same things over and over again.
I like to travel,
even though I have to travel all the time.
I don't lecture.
I'd rather stay home.
I pretty much eat the same food all the time and go to the same three or four
restaurants all the time.
Right.
I like to follow routine as much as I can.
You know,
it's even in Jujitsu,
I do the same basic movements all the time.
I have the same,
you know,
I've talked about like a funnel,
like everywhere that you go with me,
it's going to lead to where I want you to be because I'm going to use those same
moves,
surf the same spots all the time.
So I guess,
I guess for me,
the way that discipline is weakness or whatever for me is that it may,
I think I'm,
I can be fairly boring and predictable for other people.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
people say,
Hey,
you want to go try this thing?
And I'm like,
oh no,
not really.
Not really.
Yeah.
Don't really want to.
I think you're right about that though.
Cause I'm the same thing even are you the same way?
Exact same way,
bro.
Like I,
I'm not highly disciplined.
Echo Charles,
highly disciplined.
I mean,
but like the same stuff over and over again.
The,
it's funny I go to,
I don't even like new movies.
Oh Dang.
Okay.
Like,
Oh,
you know what?
I haven't had time to watch movies for a long time,
but,
but when I used to watch movies and be like,
okay,
I'm going to watch the big Lebowski again.
Yeah,
we'll have that kind of to,
I think big Lebowski is the kind of move you then,
okay,
so movies are different.
I'm going to go into a whole thing about this,
but there's two types of different mu two types of movies in this situation.
There's movies that are like,
oh awesome,
good storyline,
maybe a great reveal at the end or twist or whatever.
And it's like,
good,
good story.
And then there's like the type of movie that's just a series of good parts where
the story,
it doesn't really matter that much.
Some of that was good,
some of the junk,
but it's less about that.
It's more about like the good parts is like,
oh,
this part in this way.
That's how the big Lebowski is like it's just a series of really good parts.
Yeah,
and it's awesome.
Yeah.
That's what I mean.
I think they're both awesome,
but the,
the ones that have,
what was the other one that just the storylines awesome.
Like you know,
like,
um,
I can't think of anything off top of my head,
but big Lebowski is one of those ones you'd like Napoleon dynamite.
Like that's another one.
It's just a bunch of good parts.
Who cares about what happens within,
in fact,
you probably forget really.
I mean you remember what happened at the end of this for the storyline.
You don't really care,
but you'll watch it over and over because all the parts are funny or good or
whatever.
And then like point break for example.
I know we talked about the first,
yeah.
Yeah,
that's a good,
that's a series of great parts.
Like I certainly more the skydiving part that we'll give him of the all the
part.
They're just really fun.
I mean sure the story is good.
It's cool.
It's fine.
We'll say that,
but that's not the point.
The point is like,
you know,
anyway,
Jack,
back to the point though is oh,
when we were talking about like being repetitive,
like,
like in the same thing over and over.
It's boring.
Boring,
boring,
boring.
Yeah.
Cause I,
okay,
so I'm like that right?
Where I eat a lot of Sushi all the time and there's a Sushi restaurant within
walking distance of my house.
Like it's like borderline drive,
but I go there like not as much as I probably go like maybe three times a week
now.
But there is a point where I was going five to six days a week for real and
there'd be times where I'd go more than once in a day.
Yeah.
Day.
So of course they just love me and,
and my brother goes to,
so yeah,
they just love me in there.
Who's like,
oh,
again,
we're just pretty,
no,
probably responsible for a significant portion of their revenue.
My wife,
she's not like that.
Oh,
she likes the different minister,
the same variety and whatever.
And so my wife will say,
you know,
well,
let's say we're going to go out for dinner.
Yeah.
That's try something different.
I said,
okay,
tell me where.
Yes,
when we just go to old faithfuls.
Yeah,
yeah.
At least you have a few like different spots I have,
I have two and they're both Sushi places.
So it's like,
I mean,
and it goes for like what we do too during the weekend.
It's like really repetitive.
My wife uses the word groundhog day planning like a lot too.
If he can have great movies,
great parts,
a bunch of great parts.
But really who cares at the end,
you know,
like the story.
What's that?
What's that movie really about though?
What's the story about that movie you didn't know?
Yeah,
I totally know.
I've seen it look fun.
You gotta be nice to the girls.
So the ground hall outdate stops like,
well,
I don't know what the,
it doesn't even make sense what I did,
but it's a good movie anyway.
So that was the point of the makeup with the loose fitting.
But,
um,
but yeah,
so the point is with this is that yeah,
you will be boring because my wife thinks I'm born in that way where it's like,
it's just the same old,
same old every single time.
I'm like,
probably I love the same old thing.
I want to travel home to go onto this all inclusive thing or whatever.
This is just the whole like,
wait,
this is like way better,
you know?
And Yeah.
So,
yeah,
I think you're right.
I think that might be,
but so if you think discipline isn't your biggest strength,
what is,
what do you think your biggest strength is?
I don't know.
I don't think I have any real big strength.
You know what I think it is?
I think it's arguable.
Maybe discipline.
Yeah.
Maybe,
maybe not.
But you know what actually balance.
Yep.
Oh man,
you're imbalanced.
Nope.
You're pretty balanced.
Yeah.
You know,
I think it is,
you told it to me too.
Oh,
your durable.
in terms of physical,
I think even mental too though.
That's the thing.
Like you're,
you're like a durable pro.
You know how like people like you,
you've told me stories,
obviously what I'm going to them.
But you told me stories about someone who made like huge mistakes,
you know,
with you and you like handle it and it doesn't seem like it bothers you.
You don't like that can stuff stuff that like,
yeah,
no I do well and you know,
to me,
I guess that's,
that's balanced to me,
but to me balances,
I don't,
it's,
it's also boring,
right?
Cause I don't go far in one direction the other direction.
I don't get extreme about this or extreme about that.
I just,
I,
I think that's what has been good for me was I never freak out about stuff much,
much.
Yeah.
Some stuff.
That,
yeah.
That makes sense.
Nick's question,
what's your biggest strength?
My biggest strength.
I'll tell you what I think you're,
his biggest strength is one.
You're humble,
you're super humble.
Yeah.
That can get help.
Just the other day you were telling me you are the most humble guys in the
world.
Nobody's more humble than me.
That was
so funny though.
I forget who said that joke,
but yeah.
Yeah.
Me,
I had a,
I had one of the most egotistical persons that I've ever known.
Like I am not kidding about this.
Yeah.
Straight up.
Tell me.
I have no ego.
I mean it was,
it was like,
it was completely insane.
I couldn't believe that,
that this individual was saying it and I was just thinking to myself,
man,
that's crazy.
Ego Is,
here's the thing.
I don't know who you're talking about,
but specifically,
but um,
I will say this where obviously I wasn't all,
I don't,
and this may even go along with the idea that you think that humble is like,
I don't even know if,
if I'm humble or not because I know before I wasn't humble before at all.
I thought the world revolved around,
not necessarily like a bad way,
but just,
just,
just how.
Yeah.
It's Kinda like if I had certain feelings,
like they were just more important than what was kinda going on.
And it wasn't like necessarily like errr like walking,
you know,
like a dick or nothing like that.
It was just,
that's kind of how I felt or whatever.
And um,
you know,
complete immaturity.
But at the same time,
when you,
when you kind of pointed out that humility is like a super important thing,
I was like,
okay,
how can I,
I mean,
okay,
I'm going to assume that's true because you know what you're talking about.
So what does that even mean?
And then what I realized is a big,
like a way to exemplify humility is to,
to,
I dunno,
the ability to learn things from someone who might not necessarily be an expert,
for example.
Okay.
I think you can learn stuff from a kid,
from a blue belt.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And so from a white belt,
So that kind of stuff.
But someone with ego or we'll be like,
hey,
I'm a black belt,
so for sure.
What do you have to say to me?
You know,
gee,
you know,
that concept,
that idea.
Well,
interestingly in Jujitsu you could take it to the extreme of where there was
times where people fought.
You can't learn anything from wrestlers.
You can't learn anything from judo.
You can't learn anything from samba.
You,
you know,
that's,
that's crazy talk,
you know?
And,
and the good,
you did two players take it something from wrestling and take something from
Judah,
take a,
from wrestling a bunch from
general bonds from sambal or,
but,
and then create their own stuff and watch on youtube somebody that does other
stuff from a different academy at different school.
Yeah.
So it's almost like there's two different types of humility where,
you know,
how like someone who's really outwardly like,
um,
you actually,
you had this example where like Conor McGregor for example,
we're out,
like to hear them talk and stuff like that,
you'd be like,
Oh,
this guy has a huge ego and there's no humble,
there's no humility with them whenever,
but like he's learning all this stuff from like people you'd be like,
oh,
he's training hard.
Yeah.
Because he knows he's,
he's humble.
Yeah.
So what does that,
you know,
like is there two kinds of humbleness and your humility?
I think they're kind of,
and even if we were to look at it,
there's some level of showmanship with Connor,
right?
There's some level of selling fights with Connor,
but even at the same time like let's say that because there's such thing as
people,
probably pretty common that people are legitimately like into themselves in that
way.
Which category?
We're going to have coach cabin on this podcast at some point.
Yeah.
Cause I've gone back and forth with him on social media.
Yeah,
that'd be awesome.
Yeah.
But he could answer that question very well.
Just in general or about Connor?
Yeah,
about Connor.
He goes Connor product better than anybody.
But you get people who are legitimately cocky outwardly,
you know,
Kinda like er,
but,
but at the same time they can learn from,
they have the humility to learn from everyone kind of thing.
And you know what it is almost even,
it might not even be necessarily specifically being able to learn from everyone.
It's more about what you said long time ago.
It's like admitting to yourself that you don't know everything yet and you don't
necessarily know more than everyone at every single time.
It's like you have to be humble enough to know that you don't know everything.
So listen up kind of fat is the type of thing where even
so I will catch myself and I used to catch myself doing that,
let's say once a day and then,
and then it was once a week and there's once a month and,
and,
and it's pretty,
it's a less now,
but sometimes I'll,
I'll,
I'll catch myself listening to someone and I'll catch myself thinking,
oh,
this guy does know what he's talking about.
You know what I mean?
And as soon as I hear myself sounding and wait a second,
take a different perspective because you,
what can you not,
not this guy doesn't know anything.
It's what can you learn from this person?
That's the question.
Yeah.
What can you learn from it?
You can learn something from him,
even if he's a white belt.
Even if he's inexperienced,
even if he seems completely arrogant and crazy.
Even if you're learning how not to act.
Yeah.
That's better than just saying,
oh this person,
oh no listeners person,
I've got nothing to learn.
No you do.
I do.
So I,
it's interesting as we talked about how you make excuses,
you personally make excuses last.
Now I personally make excuses.
I might be a little ahead of you.
I'm happy cause I can,
I figured that out maybe a little bit earlier and I'm older than you,
but it's,
you know,
I used to probably make excuses once,
once a day.
Yeah.
And then once every three days and then once a week and it comes in plenty,
many forms to the home making excuses cause it doesn't necessarily only mean
making excuses to others.
It's like to yourself.
For sure.
That's the primary.
Yeah.
That's the primary,
the easy one to overcome is making excuses to other people.
The hard one overcome is making excuses to yourself.
That's the hard one.
Overcome.
Cause it hurts more.
Yeah.
Because the minute you say,
well,
you know,
I didn't get to the thing I wanted because of all these external forces,
external forces,
the minute you start saying that is the minute that you stop working hard for
that thing,
when maneuvering for that thing or adjusting for that thing or getting up early
and chasing that thing down,
it becomes an excuse,
an excuse.
It becomes an excuse like meaning who just excused you.
So who did you just excuse yourself from that workout?
Um,
yeah,
but how would say back to the humility thing,
and I don't know,
I'm just listening to you at this point where maybe I am,
because I've always had had at least a little bit of that where it'd be like
maybe this person right now,
even though I hate what they're saying to me,
like they could be right,
it could be right about me right now.
And I think always had that.
I think that's why,
you know,
some people,
they just,
you talk to me Norman,
whatever,
and you're like,
the chance of this person changing how they are is very low.
Most people,
most most people,
right?
And most people start to change my experience too.
But yeah,
something either really big or something really small has to happen over and
over and over.
Don't do this in a different for sure.
But I would say legitimately,
and I'm trying to look at it as honestly as possible.
Where me 10 years ago is like,
like if let's say I know someone I knew someone 10 years ago and I haven't seen
him or heard from him or whatever in 10 years and they like hung out with me for
a week,
they would be blown away.
They'd be like,
you're just way different.
There's like a whole different person.
It's the same with me.
I mean,
so,
so this is funny.
There's a bar in San Diego sure.
That I used to go to when I was back in the teams and of course,
yes.
And I was a wild,
yeah,
I was a wild.
Yeah.
And there was a guy that was,
uh,
a Dj there and I didn't even know.
It didn't record.
I was,
I was usually not in a state to even be paying attention to those kind of things
anyways.
To make a long story short,
I decided I was going to put it in an officer package and I put together the
package and I went into the administrative office at seal team one and I talked
to the chief that was in there and I said,
hey,
how are you doing chief?
You know,
I'm putting in this package.
And I was just wanting you to take a look at it and you know,
if there's anything you see I should add.
And he looked at me,
he goes,
I hear putting in a package,
Huh?
And I said,
yeah.
And he goes,
oh that's,
I wouldn't expect that for me it's the phrasing.
And I was kind of why not?
He goes,
w usually know I'm the,
I'm the DJ on this bar on,
on these nights.
And I've been that for five years.
And I said,
I was not aware of that.
And you know,
in his mind he was thinking that's what he knew me as.
He didn't really know me cause he's in the admin office.
He wouldn't really know me from anything else.
And that was a little bit of a wakeup call,
but that,
so my point is
I want to,
I should not,
I should never come off as a saint
for sure,
for sure.
Not at all.
And even,
you know,
to this day still working and still trying to figure things out.
But,
but definitely back in the day I was an idiot.
I had fun,
but I was did a lot of dumb stuff.
But you're,
I mean,
and I,
I believe you 100% where you were probably a certain way back then and you know,
whatever it fit,
it was fun.
It was all this or whatever and,
but you legitimately changed a bunch or a big part of fundamentally who you are
with being open to like critique and criticism and learn and whatever.
And I think,
yeah,
I think the biggest thing is I had open eyes,
you know what I mean?
And as I moved into leadership positions,
when I saw,
I saw how other people perceived me and I saw the importance of leadership and
yeah,
I mean you just,
you just have to change.
And that's something that as a leader you,
you see this all the time.
What got you here isn't necessarily what's going to get you there.
Right?
And so if you have leaders that
if they were aggressive golden cowboy when they were out in the field,
that's great,
but will you,
can you,
you have to,
you don't have to stop that,
but you have to put some rains on it.
You have to,
you have to reign it in a little bit.
The more senior you get,
the more you become accountable to a board,
the more you become accountable to being a publicly traded company.
Those are the things that were real.
And the more you become accountable to the actions.
If you're in the military still in Wa,
the way you're going to be seen,
the way,
the way your unit is going to be seen and perceived by other senior leaders.
Those are real things.
And if you don't grow up,
you don't make the progress that you need to make.
Yeah.
And I was lucky enough to see that.
You know,
I had some great examples along the way.
Great leaders that I worked for,
but it can be hard to see that.
Yeah,
that's a good like expression.
When you said I,
I opened my eyes or I went in with open eyes,
I don't even know how to describe it,
but
I just was aware of what was happening a little bit more of than normal or a
little bit enough to make the changes,
I guess.
Yeah.
And that's the hard part,
right?
And I think it is because of,
like I said,
like your,
your ego.
And it's hard for me to even really say that because like even when I say the
word ego,
it really like it,
it registers as like this external at the guy walking around with his chest out
and I dunno his Mohawk,
I dunno,
whatever.
It's like that it's an external expression,
but it's not,
it's like,
it's like being able to kind of shed the blinders on self critique.
And so,
you know,
when someone sells you,
hey,
like you're,
you're kind of acting this way or you're kind of this way and to be able to be,
to figure to yourself that this person could be right first and then be mad at
the fact that they just insulted you second of course.
Cause that's gonna be part of it.
I understand.
But most times for,
I think most people and me included sometimes where the fact that you stepped to
me like that impacts me more than what you're actually saying can.
I mean,
but if you don't have the,
the ego in the way that you describe it,
you'll,
you'll hear what they're saying first and then decide whether or not to be mad
at it.
You know what else is weird too,
is like,
as I talk about this stuff,
like,
like when I talk about detachment now,
I used to,
I used to not know that word when I would tell guys to do it.
This is even,
you know,
not that long ago,
but I was still in the teams but it took me a while and the teams while I was
trying to tell guys that,
but I didn't figure out the words yet,
you know,
you got you.
And that's just one example.
There's a bunch of examples like that where I was trying to convey him,
I would convey the message,
but I didn't just have like a concise way to do it or a clear way to do it.
But I was still conveying the same message and maybe it,
and that's another thing that happens is as you get older and you get more
experienced,
you understand the message yourself better.
Just like when you teach Jiu Jitsu or you teach anything,
the more you teach it,
the better you understand it.
And so as I taught things,
I understood it better.
And so that's one thing that I think helps out a lot.
And this is why it's an exam,
an answer from me on so many different things with leadership.
People say,
well,
what do I do with this young person that doesn't listen to what do I do?
This person that isn't reaching their potential and was like,
well put them in charge of stuff.
Cause that's what I,
that's what I think helped me a lot was even in my first platoon when I was the
youngest guy and I was the most junior guy in my first platoon,
I was the,
I was the head radio man,
which meant I was responsible for stuff I,
which meant I sat through the briefs and I had to help with the planning.
I had to do like stuff that was outside my realm of experience and I had to step
up and do it.
And it seems like a little thing right now,
but it will tell you what,
when you're 19 years old and you're in charge of the communications for some
training exercise and you don't know what the hell you're doing,
step up and figure that stuff out.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's very,
very impactful.
So that's what you do with your junior leaders that you want to have them step
up and lead.
You put them in charge of things.
You put that and that was very lucky that I had leaders that I worked for that
did that and I've talked about him before.
I mean they had leaders that that put myself and the other junior guys and
platoons in charge of things.
Not just not just saying what but actually putting us in charge of things and
that that's a quick way to grow leaders.
So I was very lucky that I had that and I think that was one of the things that
help me to see the light right was being put in Georgia things even at a young,
younger age.
When do you think like how you,
how you just talk about detaching right?
Where you were trying to convey that message before you even called it detaching
or whatever.
When did you understand the importance of,
I've told the story before and here is I was,
I was doing oil rigs training and we came up on a platform and have an oil rig
there.
There are different platforms or different levels I should say.
Yeah,
and we came up on this one platform.
I was,
I think this was,
this was in my,
I'm trying to think of was my first or second platoon.
I'm pretty sure it was my second platoon.
And as we came up on this,
this level,
okay.
It was,
it was a little confusing.
And did the whole platoon gets online and no one does anything.
I,
I basically stood there for a second and then I kind of stepped back off the
line of,
but when I looked around and I said,
okay,
I see what we should do.
And I actually said,
hold left clear,
right.
Or whatever this little call was,
and everyone did it.
And the only reason I understood that was because I stepped back like a foot and
looked around and that's all you,
that's,
and I realized right then,
Oh,
if I'm not staring down my gun,
if I take a step back,
if I look around,
if I detach,
I didn't use that word because I didn't know that word.
Right,
right.
But I said,
Oh,
if you just step back and you high port,
you're gunning,
you look around,
you're going to know way more than anybody else.
That staring down,
they're gone.
And that right there changed my world.
It really did.
It changed my world and at the time I didn't think that changed my world.
I just said,
oh cool.
You know what?
When we,
yeah,
when people are are frozen,
take a step back and look around and make a call.
Okay,
that's cool.
That's what I started doing.
I didn't think it was a big deal at the time.
I didn't think it was a big deal until I was an instructor position and I would
see everyone staring down their gun and no one making decision and all I'd have
to do is tell someone,
hey,
you take a step back with me right here.
One foot back off the firing line and look around and they'd go,
okay,
we can go to this burn right here and we'll be out.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's right.
Then I started to realize how important it was and I started to put words around
it and put,
put messaging around it that it was important.
And there's an,
every lesson that I talk about was all kind of learned in that method.
Yeah.
All that was kind of learned by being put in situations where I had to figure
something out or something occurred or,
or I you and that's the same thing with my life will go put in some situations.
I said,
okay,
you know what and what,
what I think might be kind of key about that particular idea of detaching is
when you can detach in life,
right?
It gives you this incredible ability to see yourself.
And I think that if we go down to the core of,
of myself improving as a leader and continuing to try and improve as a leader,
it's because if you can detach and see yourself,
cause that's the same exact thing.
Like I mentioned this earlier,
I said,
you know,
I kind of saw myself and saw how other guys were seeing me.
Well,
you've got to detach from.
But in order to see how other people are seeing you,
you've got to be able to detach a little bit and understand it.
And so that ability to step back and see myself from other people's,
to see myself in situations and see how other people were interacting with me
was very,
very helpful.
Now,
this does not mean that I was able to just correct course overnight,
and I don't want to make that,
you know,
anyone think that,
and I did dumb stuff when I was,
uh,
when I was a assistant platoon commander and I did dumb stuff when I was a
platoon commander and I did dumb stuff when I was a task and a commander and I
did dumb stuff when I was a training commander.
And I do,
I'm going to do something dumb tomorrow,
watch me.
But I think I will recognize it.
Most of the time I look at it and say,
you know what,
that was dumb and don't do that again.
Or here's how you can avoid it.
And I think that's what will help people.
If people can can adapt that little skill of stepping back off the off the line
and taking a look around.
Let taking a look at yourself,
look at how you're being perceived.
What else is important is,
is how to actually think about how echo is perceiving me.
Right?
Because if I'm in my own head,
I can't,
I can never see how you're seeing me.
But sometimes if you're acting,
look,
the first thing I do when someone's acting weird to me or I don't understand why
someone's acting a certain way as I put myself in their shoes,
it's hard to do that.
And if you don't do that,
you don't make real,
you can't understand them.
So if my boss is doing something crazy to me and all I do is get pissed at him
for doing something crazy,
that's what we've just created,
created an antagonistic relationship and now things are going sideways and it's
not good.
If my boss is doing something crazy me and I said,
wait a second,
why is he doing this?
Let me think about what he's saying.
Oh,
he's seeing Jocko,
the caveman looking guy that wants to go out and he seems crazy and okay,
I need to,
I need to correct that.
I needed to correct that thing.
I need to let him see that I'm thinking about the big picture and that I
understand this.
Right.
Okay.
Let me make those adjustments as opposed to real stupid using good screw him.
No detach,
check other people's perspectives.
And that's a big key
right there where you were,
like you said,
the moment you kind of made me realized the importance of this significance of
detaching,
right?
The oil rig campaign and then campaign.
It was a training off,
not that big of a deal.
To me that's a campaign,
the and then how you understood at whatever point that that applies to life ism
because I man,
that's,
I'd say those two things.
Understanding that you don't know everything and being able to detach with just
borderline impossible by the way.
Under most circumstances.
Yeah.
And as far as applying it to like,
like because like even in the military it's like that's a very specific
environment.
Military,
like unlike most environments seeming
like if you come,
you know,
like I was talking about like,
well I don't know,
go into the post office or going to the grocery store or dealing with my wife or
something like that.
But like when you go deep enough,
detaching is going to serve the exact same significance.
Good in all situations.
You know,
your,
your wife comes home,
you know,
pissed because,
I dunno,
whatever,
you know how you said the first reaction,
what you feel like doing,
which you,
not you,
but which one may typically do is react accordingly according to how I feel
about what you're saying to me.
You shouldn't be saying this stuff to me.
I didn't do anything to do.
Why are you doing this to me?
You know,
they're only dishes or whatever.
Escalate,
escalate,
escalate.
That's what was happening is that,
that's all,
that's not what you're thinking.
You're just thinking,
Hey,
this isn't fair.
This is wrong what you're doing to me,
so I'm going to,
you know,
express that or whatever.
But that's cause you're not detached like you just did.
And when you're able to do it again,
borderline impossible.
But when you find a borderline impossible,
have you made progress in that arena?
Hugely.
Here's the,
here's the snow boarder line.
If possible.
That's an expression.
It's me possible.
It's word landing.
I say it's borderline impossible because that's the last thing you feel like
doing.
So if you operate in your life,
which isn't natural by the way with how you feel,
you know,
like,
I'm just going to stress on myself.
You know what it's like.
It's like this.
Um,
it,
it's like you're doing something
and you have to do something completely different.
Yeah,
right.
Just imagine that you're walking down the road and now all of a sudden you're
walking down the road.
Maybe you're even jogging,
you're jogging down the road.
Now all of a sudden in a split second,
you've got to like go read a book.
Like right at that moment in time while your running lights like that radical of
a change.
Like it's something totally,
that's what it feels like when you detach from the current situation.
You're in this,
you're in this thing,
you're in this thing and you have to completely go and do something completely
different.
That's what it feel.
It feels like that radical of a thing when you,
when you really do it.
And when you do it,
like when you're in a,
you
know,
let's say an argument with someone,
he did a heated argument.
Yeah.
It feels like you're going from running a thousand miles an hour to,
uh,
to like putting your face in the snow and reciting the alphabet backwards.
That's helpful.
It just totally different.
And so the,
you know,
that's why,
and people are going to ask any,
they've asked us before,
well how do you detach?
And then we'll,
the,
the biggest thing I think you have to do is you have to figure out what your red
flags are.
What are the things that show you that you're too engulfed in the situation and
then recognize those things and then go put your face in the snow and started
reciting the alphabet backwards.
Cause that's what it feels like to detach.
But if you think about the advantage that you have,
and,
and I know you're a football player,
I'm not,
but you know,
you can watch everybody that's watching the football game on TV can see every
mistake that's being made as it's happening.
And everyone else on the field is,
they're trying to,
they can't compensate for him fast enough.
They're in the game.
Yeah.
And usually it's on the quarterback,
by the way,
nick,
I was wide open when you go to that.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
100% so you have that advantage if you can do that.
Yeah.
If you can manage to do that in like another cool thing about the situation is
yet I say borderline impossible,
but the more you can actually pull through and do it,
the more you can do that,
the easier it becomes.
And when it becomes like habit,
it really all it is.
And you can do weird like metal,
which I'm kind of a fan of doing little metaphors with yourself,
you know?
So if it's like you ever watched those movies?
No.
Where the movie's going on and then the person that,
what do you call him?
The protagonist,
like he pauses the movie and everyone in the movie positive and then he starts
explaining that is it you?
So it's like you do that to yourself though.
So yourself as audience.
So you go boom,
wife comes home pissed you didn't,
I don't know,
clean up the dogs,
whatever or I dunno,
whatever.
You didn't move along.
How about that?
She's pissed,
right?
You can easily move along tonight.
You can easily mold on tomorrow whenever.
Right.
But she's pissed,
right?
You don't think so.
So what you do is right when you feel yourself or right when you get her yelling
at you,
boom,
pause the movie.
What do we have here?
We have myself,
we have life.
She's mad at something.
Doesn't make sense.
What would make,
you know?
It's like then you just detach at that point if you can't make sense.
Yeah.
How are we going to solve the problem?
Like,
you know how you said like the football game,
when you,
if you can pause the movie at that,
at that point,
step back you will easily make sense of because you'll be like,
oh,
guess what?
My wife,
I haven't been home for four days.
Yeah.
I left a bunch of laundry out.
Yeah,
the baby was diaper was dirty and I forgot to throw it away.
Um,
um,
okay.
I see where she's not mad about the law and specifically as opposed to things I
did wrong.
And so you say,
Hey,
you know what?
I totally should have mowed the lawn.
And by the way,
the diapers,
that was,
that was completely out of hand.
You know what I mean?
And,
and you diffuse and you deescalate the situation.
You're detached and that's how you,
that's how you roll.
Yeah.
That's how you
make it through it.
And here's a little side tip
on
that situation.
Alon.
The diapers or whatever.
It's not that that the grass is long and she wants it short and the fact that
it's long is making her mat,
that's not the situation.
The situation is.
She said something.
She thought that that meant something that she said something she thought it
meant something to you when it came time to prove whether or not that meant
something to you,
you've proved it,
did it.
That's what you're dealing with.
That's what you guys are dealing with and that's easy to figure out when you
detach.
It's hard to what I figured out.
Yeah.
When you're in the heat of the moment,
when you're in the game,
it's hard to see who's open and who's not.
Some of the time,
most of the time.
Pretty sure all of the time in my case.
All right,
next one.
Next question.
I think this question is a good,
good lead.
That last answer was a good lead into this next question.
Yeah.
How do you think,
okay
young Jocko would've performed under commander
willing,
all young joc on their old job.
They see that reaction that you just had?
Yeah.
It is what I expected because it seems like it should be like a really
interesting question with like a really interesting answer,
but it actually isn't that interesting to me to be quite honest with you.
If Young Jocko was working for old Jocko,
it would have been good to go.
I would have liked me as a young guy and as a young guy would have liked me as a
boss.
I was a young,
hard worker with a good attitude and sometimes it got a little bit wild as I,
as I mentioned a little bit earlier.
But I could have been tightened up by the right leader.
And I wasn't like,
okay,
I wasn't,
um,
it wasn't ever interfering with work and all your wild shit.
Wild.
My wildness,
you know,
we're getting wild.
We were young,
young guys with a fist full of money and young guys and the bear this and we're
just getting after it and you know,
the guys.
But,
but we weren't like causing major trouble.
Right.
We weren't getting arrested much.
Yeah.
We weren't getting in fights all the time.
You know,
we were causing some problems,
but it wasn't nothing major.
So we do been tighten up and we got tightened up sometimes,
but it would have been no factor.
And
as a young guy,
mmm.
You know,
I,
I think I would've,
I would've liked working for me because I would have looked at myself and didn't
like,
oh that guys fired up.
You want to get after it?
And then that would have been cool with me.
So,
so again,
I don't think it's,
I don't think it's like,
uh,
it sounds like a really interesting question,
but it's not really that interesting.
And the cool thing is there's a lot of young team guys that are like,
I was when I was young team guy.
Yeah.
It's,
so I was like,
I was looked at old young team guys like,
Oh yeah,
I remembered.
I was like that.
Good for him.
Hey,
good for him.
He's fired up.
Would there be any issues though?
You know,
like as young Jocko,
who do you think,
or not who,
but what you think would be your
major struggle,
you know,
any,
even
with my,
with the boss.
Yeah.
Nah,
no,
we would have been cool.
We've been cool.
Yeah.
And the fact of matter is,
I mean like 95% of the young buck team guys that worked for me.
I love those guys.
They were awesome and no issues.
Yeah.
So you're,
you were like,
you essentially on the path then really,
you know,
with some loose ends.
For sure.
Yeah.
It was on the path.
And you know,
my,
the guys that I got went to buds with that showed up and she'll team one
old Jocko would have loved all those guys.
Yeah.
They were all fired up.
I was nothing special.
I don't know.
I'm not trying to say I was special because I wasn't,
there was guys that were way better than me.
And you know,
that's,
to go back to your question earlier when I described myself like as my good
quality being durable,
the reason I say that is cause like there's guys that were better at me than
that just about everything like faster than me,
stronger than me,
better shots than me,
whatever.
I was pretty durable though.
Like I was pretty,
I was good at being average and a lot of different things.
So I was a strong average and a lot of different things,
which is good and I was durable like I could,
I could take some abuse and mental and physical abuse,
which is,
which is a cool quality to have,
you know?
Very much so.
You're like a tank that just can't,
yeah,
and again,
I'm not trying to,
I'm no superman,
but I'm durable.
You know that that makes sense.
You know the,
you know like the,
the Toyota High Lux,
you know Toyota,
I'll have Alexis who is,
it's a,
it's a Toyota truck.
They have him overseas,
their diesel and they're really,
really durable.
Really?
There's a,
there's a show from England,
my wife's from England.
There's a show in England.
It's called top gear.
My son watches the show top gear.
They tried to destroy it to a Toyota High Lux.
They were doing just crazy things to it.
It's a really durable,
it's not the fastest,
it's not the strongest,
but it's durable.
Durable is a good quality to have just continued.
I got asked the other day,
you sweats.
Okay,
you should do Olympic lifting.
I went,
Bro,
I'm not even in the Ballpark,
you know,
compete with Olympic,
just crazy talk.
Crazy Deb.
I'm sorry.
That's anything.
Then you start competing.
You better.
Yeah.
Crazy talk check.
So yeah,
young,
young buck Jocko,
he would had a good time and old Jocko.
Like I say,
man,
there's,
there's a ton of young team guys fired up.
I was,
I was out with some young teen,
I was out with some team guys and there were some young young team guys there
and some of these young guys are
awesome and like,
yeah,
you know what?
You know people say like,
oh,
millennials and the SNLP,
America's getting weak.
I'm like,
I'm gonna go hang out with some of those guys.
They're 20 years old.
I'm like,
you know what?
We're going to go,
we're good to go.
We got snow guys that are beasts solid.
Yeah.
Beyond solid freaking awesome.
My,
my two friends that are in the d Jeremy cake nuts.
Think talking to them now,
like the maturity level is just really like really impressive maturity levels,
especially for both of them.
But at the same time thinking back on them and how they kind of,
when they started,
when they were like,
yeah,
we're going in the seal teams,
all this stuff.
Considering that and then considering where they are now,
it makes,
it seems the same to me where the older them wouldn't have a problem really with
no longer then it's like they were on the path.
Oh sure.
Path for sure.
Those kind of guys I'm talking about like those guys,
I would love to have those guys working for me when I was,
when I was a commander and I would love to have those guys as my chief when I
was a young guy.
Yeah,
no,
no factor.
Yeah.
So like I said,
I think people thought that sounded like an interesting question.
But yeah,
unfortunately like you're in a meeting.
All these
crazy was some crazy stuff.
What about socially though?
No,
not socially,
but what did he say?
Like in like outside of the military,
you know,
chat all,
I mean I was a young kid and as an older guy you look at the young kids and you
go,
yeah,
you know he's young,
he's getting after it.
God bless him.
Let's rock and roll.
I got to let me keep them out of trouble.
Yeah,
that's all good.
All good.
I think I might have some problems with myself.
Young Echo.
Oh cause younger echo wasn't on the path yet.
No,
I don't know.
Yeah,
there was no path.
I didn't even see a path really.
I Dunno.
Maybe
next question.
What advice would Jocko give his 17 year old self regarding school,
social relationships,
parents,
peer pressure,
et Cetera.
Yes,
exactly.
The actual Jocko podcast tonight is like,
all these questions are about Daca actually.
That's kind of what I was asking.
Like outside of the military,
you know,
if I was going to tell myself something,
here's a couple of things,
you know,
I would tell myself to detach.
I tell him,
tell him myself to learn that.
I would tell myself that that girl isn't the whole world and those friends
aren't the last friends are ever going to have and the party isn't going to be
the best party of all time and all those things that you've think it,
this is what we talked about earlier.
All of those things that you think are a huge deal when you're young,
they're not a big deal.
And I know that's Kinda messed up,
but it's true,
man.
It's true.
The things that you think are a big deal when you're 17 years old,
I'm not that big of a deal.
And it's really hard to convince someone that's 17 years old yeah.
Of that,
right?
Oh yeah.
They also also,
what they don't recognize is things that are a big deal.
They don't recognize.
They think they're a little deal.
So they,
they're doing stupid things,
right?
Yeah.
Whether it's drinking and driving weather,
I mean kids still drink and drive now.
Like how dumb is,
that?
Seems crazy.
And just so people don't think,
you know,
nowadays we've talked about social media or a two,
but people post stuff on social media and you cool man,
what is wrong with you?
And I guess,
you know,
I've heard now,
we work with a lot of different companies.
When you apply for a job,
they go and look at your social media and see what kind of an idiot you might
be.
Yeah,
that's a good move.
But no,
it's a great move.
It's a great move.
So,
um,
yeah,
just,
just recognize that some of the little things are actually big and some of the
big things are actually a little,
and I'd square those things away.
And the,
I've said this before,
when you're young,
you've got to realize that how you act now is directly related to your future
success,
to your future happiness,
to your future financial situation,
to everything.
So,
so it's hard to make that connection,
right?
We were young,
might be impossible.
Some kids get it though.
I'm telling you,
some kids get it.
I think they're just,
no,
some kids get it.
Some of my oldest daughter's friends,
they get it,
like they're on track,
they're on track,
they're there.
They're like,
Hey,
I'm doing this.
I'm doing that.
They're on track.
They're 16 years old.
They're studying for the sats,
they're taking the AP classes.
My daughter included,
like they're on track to make stuff happen.
Yeah.
But I think,
and I'm not thinking this is the case,
but this is probably the case one way or another.
That could be wrong.
I understand.
But okay,
so we talked about this before.
You know,
that part of your brain that understands all that that you're talking about
isn't either developed or developed.
So this is,
uh,
you know,
and this is from what I understand how you kind of influence people.
You just put them on a routine,
kind of like,
okay.
So it's the difference between understanding like what I'm doing now and having
a tangible no,
until I know where you're going with us and your,
I believe that there are definitely some kids like that that are just,
they're just like,
hey,
okay,
I'm supposed to get good grades and maybe he could grants I'm supposed to get,
they get on that track.
I know for a fact kids that are like,
no,
I am going to do this,
this,
this and it's going to lead me here.
Actually,
you know what,
you're right cause this is good.
Blake,
you know,
remember Blake and he used to do videos for yeah,
so he,
we did like a thing where it was,
I think he was like a Q and a or something,
something like that.
And he was,
he was talking about that were in elementary school.
He remembers feeling like if I don't have perfect attendance and have perfect
straight A's,
I won't pass this.
Not passed,
but I won't like be the perfect guy or whatever.
And he said that he would,
um,
it would like create like this track to his whole future in his life would be
ruined.
That's how he felt.
He goes like,
Whoa,
no,
I'm living like literally minute to minute and third grade.
It'd be like,
the reason I wanted to do my homework and get good grades,
it's so I wouldn't get in trouble straight,
straight.
It was not to get into college,
none of that stuff for sure.
And then eat some way.
Most kids are,
in my opinion,
most kids are,
hey,
I don't want to get in trouble.
Some immediate repercussions,
myself included,
hey,
I got a pass this so I can go to the next grade.
You know what I mean?
Stuff or I don't want to be the guy in class who didn't do his homework,
you know,
kind of thing.
But yeah,
I guess so.
Yeah,
I guess so that's,
that's me trying to,
I got to step outside of myself on that one.
And I guess the final thing,
obviously I'd tell myself discipline equals freedom,
which is basically what we're saying.
Yeah.
So get disciplined in how you live your life.
And that I think the biggest one there is two to whether they totally understand
it or not.
Say like what you're doing right,
right now is the important things in life.
The things that you think are important or not are not important.
And then things that aren't that you think are not in [inaudible] are important.
So it's kind of like a,
like an iceberg,
you know,
I'll be old PR,
you know the people that are more not to over that little statement.
You don't why?
Because people really like the way you say important.
You just said it eight times.
So yeah.
Well Flurry of glory and rainbows.
Emojis.
All right,
well hey,
I agree with you.
So like the iceberg thing,
you know,
you know the iceberg metaphor where it's like people only see the top of the
iceberg,
but below that is like this huge iceberg.
So that's what,
that's what important things are in life,
right?
So you think it's just this little small little iceberg.
But when you think of the whole scope of life,
which you have no access to,
by the way,
as a kid,
it's that whole iceberg,
you know?
So if you're not focusing on that important part of the iceberg,
well I guess an iceberg situation,
it's not that important,
but another metaphor.
But it will sink your ship.
Yeah.
You know,
like in that kind of situation.
Um,
but,
and then at the same time,
the things that aren't really important,
meaning they don't have an iceberg under there.
They're just a little floaty thing.
You think that's so important.
Nothing's going to melt or get cra or whatever,
you know,
not going to send,
it's not going to think you're just going to kind of,
it's a fleeting check.
A one thing before we closed out tonight cause I think that's good for
questions.
I wanted to hit a couple of quick Tim Ferriss' new book.
I want to hit a couple quick things from it.
Tribe of mentors is what it's called and um,
a lot of good info in it.
And it's written in really short little sections.
If he didn't know the shit,
I mean you can read him in like five or 10 minutes.
And what he did in this book as you took and asked the same,
I think it's 10 or 11 questions to all these different,
I would say random,
but they're not random because they're all kind of
successful in whatever realm they're going to be successful in.
Cause I guess successful is a very open term,
right?
Whatever realm they're in,
they're successful.
There's all kinds of people in here and I just,
I read like the first couple of 150 pages or so and I just wanted to do pull out
a couple of the
couple of ones that I thought were pretty cool that I thought people could take
a little something away from.
And I was like,
Tim,
can I read couple of these things?
He's like,
yeah,
go ahead.
Whatever.
Hopefully it doesn't sue me.
Uh,
anyways,
so here we go.
The first one is a little section from some excerpts and I'm not reading the
whole like everything in each person's section,
but just some of the highlights.
Steven Pressfield.
Okay.
The guy.
He's an author,
he's in the Marine Corps.
You know who Steven Pressfield is?
Sorry,
Dude.
Yeah.
He wrote the art of war.
He wrote the legend of Bagger Vance.
That's a movie war of art.
Yeah.
Sorry.
He wrote the war of art.
Yeah.
Which is obviously a play on words for,
for the art of war and the war of art is like how to be creative and how to
overcome those things to overcome the resistance and all that.
Yes,
yes.
Through Joe Rogan actually told me he used to have a stack of those books and
you just give them to people that came to,
uh,
meet him.
Yeah.
That's why I read it.
Joe Rogan.
Oh,
there you go.
And he also wrote gates of fire,
which is a freaking awesome book actually.
And it's about the Spartans at the battle of Thermopylae and they actually teach
the gates of fire,
like at the basic school for the Marine Corps and at the Naval Academy at least
I've heard that they've teach it.
So that's pretty,
that's pretty awesome.
Anyways,
okay.
Here's a question for Steven Pressfield.
The question is,
what advice would you give to a smart driven college student about to enter the
real world?
What advice should they ignore?
Here's what he said.
I'm probably hopelessly out of date,
but my advice is get real world experience.
Be a cowboy,
drive a truck,
join the Marine Corps,
get out of the hyper competitive life hack frame of mind.
I'm 74 believe me,
you've got all the time in the world.
You've got 10 lifetimes ahead of you.
Don't worry about your friends beating you or getting somewhere ahead of you.
Get out and get into the real dirt world and start failing.
Why do I say that?
Because the goal is to connect with your own self,
your own soul adversity.
Everybody spends their life trying to avoid it.
Me Too,
but the best things that ever happened to me came during the times when the shit
hit the fan and I had nothing and nobody to help me.
Okay,
who are you really?
What do you really want?
Get out there and fail and find out.
Very interesting.
Pretty,
what's funny,
I was talking to jade last night,
literally last night and he told me the same thing.
Get out there and fail.
What?
What part?
That,
whoa.
That thing.
It's like,
you know live.
So me,
when I step outside of my comfort zone,
I take one tiny step and here's the thing told you to jump.
He told me the,
yeah,
like take a bigger jump kind of thing.
He didn't tell me to do it.
He just recommended it because,
well,
you know,
my whole,
and this is probably half by the
way,
I have a comfort zone.
I'll take one tiny step and then I'll take the,
you know,
when you suppose I,
you get burned or whatever you get,
you know the whatever,
and then you grow from it.
That's what happens.
That's the whole idea.
Right?
So I take a tiny step that I take the tiny hit and then I get the tiny growth.
But I tried to do it all the time.
All the time.
But it's still safe,
man.
That's still safe because that's just like one pinky outside the comfort zone.
That's what he was saying.
He was like,
you like,
you gotta step outside because just the fact that you can endure a big fail,
you know,
he didn't go out there and fail,
right.
It's field.
So if you can endure like a big fail are too big fails or major fails,
now you have the ability to endure major failure.
You know,
that kind of thing.
That was his whole thing.
I was like,
yeah,
that makes sense.
I didn't tell him that at the time.
Oh Man,
I'm doing it perfectly.
Truck.
Uh,
next question for Steven Pressfield.
When you feel overwhelmed or unfocused,
what do you do?
Here's his answer.
I have a friend at the gym who knew Jack Lalaine.
Google him.
If the name is unfamiliar,
Jack used to say it's okay to take a day off from working out,
but on that day,
you're not allowed to eat.
That's the short way of saying you're not really allowed to get unfocused.
Take a vacation,
gather yourself,
but know that the only reason you're here on this planet is to follow your star
and do it.
The Muse tells you it's amazing how a good days work will get you right back to
feeling like yourself.
That's good info right there.
Hmm.
When I realized this,
um,
okay,
it's so easy to go down the downward spiral of eat bad food.
Feel bad,
not get good workouts,
sleep late,
sleep like crap.
Yeah.
And,
and then what do you do when you feel like crap?
You want to feel better as soon as possible.
So you do some immediate gratification,
right?
You,
you go,
Oh,
you know what?
I don't feel like working out so I'm not going to work out.
Yeah.
And then you say,
you know what?
I don't feel good.
And the reason you don't feel good,
it's because you didn't work out.
That's a,
now what you do is you like,
well,
you know what's going to make me feel better?
A donut got a beer in a beer.
And so you get the donut and the beer and then now you really don't feel like
working out.
So that's the downward spiral.
Yeah.
Break the spiral.
Break it.
Break.
What'd you call him at the other day when Jordan Peterson was on break the loop.
Yeah.
Right.
So it's the same thing.
You got to break the loop and that's what he's talking about.
When you're feeling like crap,
get after it.
That's how I translate it.
And it makes you feel better and it gets you right back on the path.
Yeah.
And that's why actually fasting is a good thing.
Fasting is a good way to get yourself read.
Reacquainted with the path real quick.
You fill your body with a bunch of junk.
Yeah.
It makes you not want to perform.
It makes you not want to work out.
It makes you not want to work.
When you're clean,
you feel good.
So hit a fast 24 hours,
you know rock and roll.
Yeah.
And I liked that.
You want to take a day off?
That's cool.
No evening.
How legit is that?
It's a real legit,
it's a real legit cause now.
Yes.
What?
At lunchtime you're like,
man,
I just want to eat something cool.
Go Bank and then you can get your grub on
or you can just work out and still muddy.
All right,
getting into the next cat here.
This guy's name is Jersey Gregorich and this guy emigrated from Poland,
the United States as a political refugee with his wife in 1986 and he won,
subsequently won four world weightlifting championships and established one
world record record,
founded the Ucla weight lifting team.
And by the way,
this guy has been on,
this guy's been on Tim's podcast as well.
This Guy Jersey,
also writer write poem,
wrote poems and had a ward winning poems.
But this is kind of a cool little statement that he wrote in here.
Uh,
he kind of goes on a little bit of a tangent,
but this isn't related to the question,
but I'm going to jump into it.
He says,
five years ago I decided to eliminate my reactive behavior to irritations,
but at first,
none of my tricks worked.
I placed philosophical and inspirational quotes on my iPhone wallpaper and wrote
in my journal,
but the proverbs always lost it effectiveness over time.
Then one day I told one of my clients who blamed her husband for everything to
take 100% responsibility for her part in the interactions this way.
I said,
you will be free of trying to control him and you will be able to find
constructive solutions in your relationship.
When she left,
I realized that the same advice could help me as well.
Taking 100% personal responsibility would help me to stop blaming or complaining
and achieve a sense of flow.
It would also give me the clarity in any conversation to locate the right words
to help a person except a hard choice.
So he's talking about extreme ownership and,
and we talk about that.
We're in,
take it out,
take an extreme ownership in a relationship with another human being.
Don't blame them.
Figured out how you're going to solve the problem yourself.
You know what this reminded me of was when captain plump was on and he was,
had his cell mate and what they do,
you remember Captain Plumb and we touched on it,
but he was saying that if their cellmate was annoying them,
because believe you know,
they're,
they're living with one other or two other or three other people for months on
end in a little freaking Hanoi Hilton cell.
And he said,
if that person,
because you can imagine how you get on each other's nerves and they all took the
APP to date if they allowed themselves.
If,
if echo is getting on my nerves,
it wasn't [inaudible] fault.
It was my fault.
Yeah,
yeah.
Mindful.
Yeah.
And that's what he's talking about here.
Then you can actually fix it.
Hmm.
That the next question that Jersey answered is this one.
If you could have a gigantic billboard anywhere with anything on it,
what would it say and why?
And here we go.
Here's what his answer was.
Hard choices,
easy life,
easy choices,
hard life,
nothing truly meaningful or lasting has ever been created in a short period of
time.
If you learn the story behind any great success,
you realize how many years went by and how many hard choices were made to
achieve it.
Reaching for more is not only an act of ambition,
it also be comes.
It also comes from passion and love.
Nothing is achieved because of easy choices.
I believe that people can endure any hardship if it is sensible and
constructive.
Hard choices means never retiring because the brain has to be engaged and
finding new solutions in the moment,
not just remembering old formulas.
Hard choices make us wiser,
smarter,
stronger and wealthier and easy choices.
Reverse our progress,
focusing our energies on a comfort or entertainment in every difficult moment.
Ask Yourself,
what is a hard choice and what is an easy choice and you will know instantly
what is right.
That's good.
What does that even need?
Commentary,
not really
make sense.
That's a great thing to think about.
Yeah,
it's a discipline equals freedom.
Yes.
Is Hard,
man.
Yeah.
You know how he said like pay now or pay later kind of thing.
You know if you want to pay later or if you want.
A lot of people they try to pay later.
You know,
I heard one the other day.
You can either suffer the pain of discipline or the pain of regret.
Right?
Same thing.
Same exact thing.
People saying the same thing must mean something.
It must mean something.
Pay attention to it.
Yeah.
All right.
Moving to the next section here.
Page one 27 from tribal mentors.
Emilia Boon.
Okay.
And she wakes up at like three o'clock in the morning.
She's here and she's four time world champion in the sport of obstacle course
racing.
I met her a couple times.
You met her too?
Yeah.
She's a beast.
And what's cool about her is she beats like she did the 2012 world's toughest
mudder competition.
It's 24 hours,
90 miles,
300 obstacles.
She finished second overall out of more than a thousand competitors,
including 80% of which are male.
Second overall.
Did I have to say something about being durable earlier?
That's adorable.
So Emilia,
awesome human.
And
last one we'll do here,
but she,
she got asked the same question.
If you could have a gigantic billboard anywhere with anything on it,
what would you say and why it?
Emilia says no one owes you anything.
We live in a world that's rampant with entitlement,
with many people believing that they deserve to be given more.
My parents raised me to be self sufficient and impressed upon me that the only
person you can really depend on them in life is you.
If you want something,
you work for it.
You don't expect it to be given.
If others help you along the way,
that's fantastic,
but it's not a given.
I believe that the key to self sufficiency is breaking free of the mindset that
someone somewhere owes you something or we'll come to your rescue.
Yeah.
No one owes you anything.
No one's coming to your rescue.
It's on you.
Obviously I couldn't agree more.
It's funny because
as she said,
I mean we,
we know the importance of a team
and you always hear people say,
you know,
you can't do it by yourself and I'm not here.
I'm here because of so many different people and that's true,
but that doesn't mean that you can sit around and rely on other people to save
you or to do the heavy lifting or even help you out in any other way.
Help from other people is a luxury.
Okay.
It's a luxury that you shouldn't count on,
so step up and own it and make it happen because no one owes you anything.
That book is tribe of Mentors,
Timothy Ferriss,
he's got Timothy,
not Timothy,
more
Timothy Ferris.
Good short life advice from the best in the world.
All right.
Speaking of helping people echo Charles.
Yeah.
Maybe you can help people
learn how support themselves.
Yeah,
and maybe if they want to also simultaneously support this podcast.
If they were to that,
that would be fantastic,
but we're not relying on it.
Is that kind of the theme?
I'm hoping they flop.
Hey,
I got this.
I'll run with it.
Sure.
Oh yeah,
sure.
Of course.
Sure.
You want me to run with it cause I'll be done with it and like four minutes
here.
What's interesting is that kind of depend on you and rely on you to kind of help
bail me out in this podcast.
Otherwise they'd just be kind of talking to myself.
Okay.
Check.
Actually I wouldn't be talking because I typically talk after you t like in
reaction to you.
So if it was the echo podcast,
it would just be silence.
Yeah.
It wouldn't even be good evening because you sick,
you know,
eh,
no podcast check.
It's all good.
So yeah,
support yourself.
Right.
All right.
We'll talk about Krill oil.
Jocko is Krill Oil Jocko.
Super Krill oil.
Super Super Grill.
Yeah.
And also Jocko Joint Warfare,
glucose.
We can join.
This is all for your joints.
Best type of supplement in my opinion.
You don't,
when have you been into other supplements?
Not in a long time.
Yeah.
So I've,
I have like in my younger days where I'll take like kind of no protein powder
like this thing does this,
you know,
I can say with full on honesty that when I stopped taking it there a difference.
You know what happens when you stop digging dirt warfare.
That's a thing.
Yeah.
So there is a difference.
And especially,
I mean,
I don't know,
I'm,
I'm whatever age I am now,
you don't have to go into that part,
but so I don't know.
I don't know how it is to take Krill oil when I was like in my twenties so I
don't know.
But I know now,
and I'll tell you this and I have gotten off it for like a,
it was like maybe a week,
little,
little bit more than a week.
And yeah,
they could,
they came back man.
The joint situations,
you know what I think,
you know what?
I think the Krill oil and the joint warfare do make you durable.
Yeah,
they do.
I believe they contribute greatly to my durability.
Yeah.
And that's,
and it's actually saying a lot for me cause and for youtube big time because
you're,
you're not like a small guy and a smart person.
And let's face it,
we're older than we were before.
That is a true statement for you.
You,
we,
you actually more so than me.
You do like hard stuff like lifting Jujitsu like hard stuff.
Harder than the normal person.
Maybe some people,
not Emilia Boon 9,300 obstacle course,
90 miles.
Awesome.
Yeah.
See what up if she's not already on it or something like it.
Nonetheless,
the joint situation is like that saying a lot.
If you can do the stuff that you do and I just kind of doing some introspection
kind of detaching,
whatever I'm looking at,
stuff that I do,
it's like men,
it helps a lot.
I don't think I'd be able to go as hard.
Oh No.
When you definitely want him to like just daily my shoulder healed.
Yeah.
My elbow straight of them.
And my knees probably put abuse so my knees with,
with like working out and Jiu cause they're kind of loose,
skinny.
I thought you said there but um,
like they're super loose.
Where when I blew out my knee in college,
the doctor,
when he,
you know,
they do the test tests,
I'm like okay.
Before they do the MRI,
they do the tests.
All of these tests,
they just kind of wiggle them and do all this stuff from different positions and
they wiggled both of them and they're like,
Bro,
your knees are loose.
Genetically,
they were skinny too.
Anyway,
they were loose.
And then do,
you said you had skinny?
I do.
And skinny ankles.
I,
um,
then I hurt my knee when I was running with Greg and I went to the doctor who
performed the surgeon bicep and he did,
he was like,
Oh yeah,
you have a blown ACL.
And I was like,
Whoa,
whoa.
I only have,
I heard the outside of my knee or the inside of any,
not the outside or not my,
I didn't blow out my knee.
It's like,
no,
you blew out your knee.
I was like,
Dang.
That was like,
oh.
But,
but he didn't run any comprehensive tests.
He just did it real quick,
like wiggled it.
And then I was like,
whoa.
My doctor in college said I have really loose needs,
so check this one.
And there is,
he had like another person there and he goes and he checks the other and he was
like,
Whoa,
whoa.
But the difference is when you wiggle a no ACL knee,
it doesn't like abruptly stop even if it's loose.
So what I'm saying,
so like if you have no ACL,
it's like,
it's like a blunt.
Like it's like if you had a,
a big a cord in there,
like a real like attention chord or something that didn't,
didn't stretch at all and mine are just a little bit longer.
You see what I'm saying?
So I have at least needs nonetheless.
So the point is,
I know long explanation,
I understand
when I rolled you just so they'll pop out sometimes loose ends and then if,
if they pop out and then I like Kik or straighten out real quick or whatever,
it'll pop out.
And you know how your bones,
there's kind of shaped like this.
They'll do this and then they'll get like caught on each other and when they get
caught at each other and you press it,
it'll mess up the cartilage.
Yeah.
So they'll get swollen on the inside.
At the end of the day they get swollen for like some days I'm going to like warm
up more or whatever.
But yeah,
I take,
I just take the Krill oil.
I don't,
I just ignore the swelling,
no factor,
and I'm pretty flexible to nonetheless.
Anyway.
You want to support yourself.
There you go.
Jocko.
Super crude oil and joint warfare.
Boom.
Physical support on your supportive structures.
Also if you're in,
did you get to origin?
Yeah.
Has a new key.
What is it?
Your signature g,
is that what you call it and all about all that.
The it says cool stuff on it.
Yeah,
because freedom get accurate.
Yeah.
So I guess technically as far as what a signature something we'd be,
yeah,
that's the Jocko.
Gee,
it's not called the Jocko Homo.
We wouldn't be having,
I guess we have a chocolate potty.
Yeah,
but that's just for a lack of a better name is really true.
This one.
Yeah.
No.
Well anyway,
they see the deaf [inaudible].
Yup.
Disciplining closer.
Edo g good on kind of lighter weight.
It's,
I'm Pete told DC.
Pete.
Pete said that the,
the we've athletic,
we've,
it's a real meal.
We've,
yeah.
It's not just taking cotton,
which is what,
which is what they just make pants from 1908 from,
it's an athletic and when you put it in the Dryer,
oh,
you put it in the washing machine.
When you get down,
it's almost dry.
It's got cotton in it,
but it's also got a poly blend.
Yeah.
The good stuff.
And it's all made here in America from the seed of the cotton,
the very seed that you plant the seed.
I wonder if where they get the seeds from Charlie here.
Either Tennessee or South Carolina.
Yeah.
So we'll find out.
You've been buying the seeds or,
or acquiring the seeds in whatever capacity is here in America.
Planted in America.
Cotton grows in American harvest did in America,
obviously died in America,
died in America.
It's up to Maine.
Repeat weaves it in a bunch of loans into fabric.
Any diggies boom,
right on your back to start rolling on.
Made in America.
That's all the stuff at the origin,
by the way,
if you don't know already.
Yeah,
they got some good rash guards and compression gear,
which is what the same thing the rash guards I've noticed cause I didn't use to
use rash guards other than for surfing.
Yeah.
Do you notice,
okay,
you feel a little bit,
uh,
like the compression helps you athletically.
Do you feel that?
I don't feel that.
No,
but the,
no,
I don't think I'm paying attention to be honest with you.
Placebo,
I'm just trying to apps.
What about people that get 19% improvement in their Jujitsu skills?
That's real.
That's 100% real but me,
what,
you know,
as far as I,
but I hear good things about compression.
Like I see the links to articles that say all the performance benefits and all
this stuff.
Here's the thing,
I don't read them.
I don't know.
So I wear knee pads when I roll.
Yeah.
And I wear them for two reasons.
Well I wear them for three reasons.
Number one,
just uh,
abrasions on the knee.
Right,
right.
Whatever.
Matt Byrne on your knee,
which is cool.
You get it.
Maybe you get it.
Maybe you get it once every three days.
That's once every three days.
You got Matt Byrne on your knee and you've got blood and you got people that are
like,
Hey,
I don't want to roll with you cause you're bleeding or whatever.
So that's just a pain number two.
It for me keeps them warm.
Right?
The ordinary sleeve.
It just warms up your knees.
And number three,
it provides a little bit of compression.
That makes me feel good.
Now I feel when I put on a rash guard,
I feel like that on my body,
which is good.
I don't know.
I think it feels good.
Yeah.
So I can't speak really on it,
but I for damn sure can't speak against it.
And it's all made in America,
in America,
and they're dope.
Do some research if that even matters.
You don't,
does that matter that much?
Well,
well you wear it because it's efficient to roll in for sure.
The most efficient thing you can roll in is a rash guard.
Yeah,
I feel like like a,
that's the uniform B.
All the,
the woody call it Ergonomic,
Ergonomic.
It's like,
you know how like you said the mat burning,
you don't give mapper and like all day every day.
Yeah.
If you're going super hard and your knee or your elbow or whatever it happens to
be against the mat at it,
you know,
it's like,
it's a happenstance situation.
Unless you knew,
unless you're new,
you're getting back burner lines,
proprioception to keep you from getting,
hey,
notice if you haven't enrolled for a long time,
you'll get your feet,
get all of mat burned up,
your knees,
get all Matt burned up.
You know when you're,
when you know when you're in the role mode,
you barely get Matt Byrne get it like once every three or four roles.
They'll the once every three or four days you'll get a little map burn on the
top of your toes.
Or Bro,
I haven't had met Brendan told him.
I told him like long time.
Oh,
it's like,
yeah,
it's like your skin gets smart.
You're like,
oh,
what are we doing?
Rolling.
Okay.
We gotta toughen up right now.
Have you ever rolled on like a resume,
right?
Wrestling Mat Barefoot after you've been rolling on a hard to Tommy Matt for
awhile.
It takes like a week to get used to it.
Why?
Because you will stub your toe a bunch cause your toes won't know where to go
cause they're deeper and softer.
It's like when you play football on grass and then you go to our artificial
material,
you've got to get used to that.
Yeah,
it's weird.
Yeah.
Well that's true.
Anyway.
Cool.
Compression gear.
Good.
I'm glad that it's compression because some people do care about that and I
think that if you know one of those people well if you know the benefits and
you're benefiting from it,
there you go.
Boom.
I just,
I don't think I just been paying attention but after this,
guess what I will because I'm not always right about things as far as the way I
look at them.
Also
also I want to talk about on it.
So I would go into my whole kettle bell routine,
which I smashed yesterday.
By the way.
I got a new cyclops one by the way.
Um,
so again,
cool.
If you there are regular kettle bells,
the regular ones that's good cause doing kettle bells is way better than not
doing Kettlebell is one I recommend is you get
the good ones.
The Dope uh,
decorative artistic deck.
I don't like decorative.
You liked decorative the word Decca?
No,
I'm here to win artistic artistic kettlebells.
I say get those ones.
They're just way cool.
Especially if you're into Instagram stuff.
That's what I think.
It's my opinion nonetheless.
They got regular ones as well.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko they have a bunch of fitness stuff I
noticed Jockos Mace that he recommended I use for like other stuff which is
actually part of a big point that you can use a lot of this stuff for like
various different sorts of exercise activities and they have like a bunch of
cool stuff on there like gum stuff that's different from your traditional bench
squat.
You know like functional stuff.
Check unless audit.com/ [inaudible] go there,
boom.
Support Yourself,
expand your workout man.
If you want,
you can be like Jocko does the same thing over and over and over and over and
over and over and over again.
Very.
Yeah,
but they vary over and over and they also have some strong,
actually,
to be honest with myself,
I do the same exact workout all the time with variations,
but those variations will come in cycles.
They go over it.
But that's kind of the whole point of a workout though.
It's like your body gets used to certain activities.
You can't let it get too used to it.
Right.
That's why they say,
you know,
you gotta switch it up,
all the shock,
your body,
all this stuff.
But if you're constantly just shocking your body,
it's like,
okay,
where do we,
your buddies kind of saying this to you.
It's like,
okay,
what are we doing?
I'm going to get as good at it as possible.
Okay,
so however many times we got to do this thing,
I'm going to try my best.
As long as you feed me and arrest me,
I'm gonna try my best to accommodate you.
As far as you know,
getting better at this thing.
No.
If you give me one thing to do and say get good at that,
we're never doing it again.
You're not there.
There's no real results except for maybe the underlying system,
you know,
maybe like your heart rate or your,
those types of things.
Maybe your um,
what do you call your,
you know,
when you can endure like hard stuff meant durable.
Yeah,
like mental durability.
Maybe that,
but no,
if you do like one exercise,
sure you'll be sore and then that's kind of hit the benefits of that program
won't really,
then again,
I don't know,
I could be wrong.
It could be missing like some new science on whole deal.
Nonetheless,
research it,
get a good workout routine and if you want to expand it,
got on it cause they have the good stuff.
Also,
if you want to get Timothy Ferriss book that Jocko was quoting,
jock was in there by the way.
How many,
how many coats do you have in there?
I Dunno.
11 disaster persons,
Jocko.
So these,
and they're the same,
right?
They're the same as the one,
all this stuff.
Yeah.
And here's the thing,
like Tim will post like little excerpts of like just little quotes,
you know?
And that's really interesting thing that he did there where he asked everyone
the same question because that's the kind of person,
Tim's personality.
He looks for patterns and yeah,
that's when,
that's how you find patterns that super cyber like it's,
so it's basically you have 11 categories of advice that you can get from these
top level people in different industries,
different.
And then he's got like,
uh,
he's,
he's kind of sorts them in the back so you can see what everyone,
he,
he kind of assembles the information in some various ways in the back of the
book.
So you can sort of pull pool the knowledge.
You haven't,
it's a quicker,
that's good.
Yeah,
man,
I actually liked that kind of.
Um,
but that is smart though.
So that's essentially what you have.
You have this big book of advice from all these complete complete experts.
That is exactly what it is.
Eh,
so there you go.
When you get that and just go here,
look,
we'll offer it Jocko,
podcast.com go on the top,
top menu books from the episodes.
Boom,
I got you right there.
Tribe of mentors by Timothy Ferriss.
Click through.
There is a good way to support if you want to shop for anything else.
Good.
Do that.
Carry on.
Men support away.
Some people think that that's not a big deal.
It is a big deal.
Just clicking through there.
I mean it is a big deal.
It's hard to do.
Easy to do.
Small action,
small action.
Big Reaction.
Yup.
Just like sodium when you throw it into water.
Anyway,
subscribe to the podcast.
Youtube.
That's for the video version,
but on iTunes and Google,
play,
stitcher,
all on podcasting,
providing platforms seems seems obvious,
but you know,
if you haven't already subscribed,
it's good way to support also youtube,
like I said,
video version of this podcast.
Also excerpts.
If you want to share a little ideas that have emerged from the podcast,
you want to share them individually.
They're on there.
Most of them,
I'll work on them every week.
Put them on there,
you can share them.
It's a good reason to subscribe to the Youtube.
Also put some,
uh,
you know how people,
what what's called?
There's like Mashups,
they're called mashups.
When you put like an excerpt of your voice,
they put music videos.
Yes.
They put some video so that,
you know from visual aid is what it's called.
Where do you make mash make?
I don't,
here's the thing though.
So a Mashup is like you just take various clips,
you know,
whatever,
like they're just visually and you do like a whole sematic thing and that's kind
of the thing.
So I don't know,
maybe a while though says and it really kind of,
I don't know,
sometimes they get hard.
Um,
yeah.
Kinda no block read the war of art or I might be just working diligently and
obsessive.
Lee On may be new approaches and methods put the war of art on their part on our
site too so people can get that.
The war of art.
Yeah.
I read down this is good.
I need to maybe revisit it for this video production standpoint.
Nonetheless,
when I do make those videos,
I put them on youtube and that's yet another reason to subscribe on top of the
fact that it does support the podcast,
so it's like a big circle loop of support.
You see what I'm saying?
Also Daca has a store,
it was called Jocko store.
[inaudible] dot com is where you can get your discipline equals freedom shirt
get after it,
shirt and other shirts of that tight.
Also rash guards on their new rash guards on there.
Two new rash guards on there,
I don't know,
two or three.
You got to look Jocko pot or Jacqueline store.com the rash guard is sodium.
Small action reaction.
That's a rash guard.
I Dunno.
I got to take the pictures.
I got to list them,
you know.
So during that process,
hopefully sound like that's real hard to get pictures and lists.
I'm,
I'm trying to,
anyone want a job out there in the world and he was a hard time taking pictures
of a rash guard warrior.
Your kid rash guards for youth for the war.
Your kids themselves.
So look out for that.
My little daughter was sporting hers today.
I know.
It looks good.
It looks very,
very,
very good.
Nonetheless,
they're on their drugstore.com cuts some hats on their beanies coming as well.
Um,
and you know,
other stuff on there.
I'm not saying go buy a beanie.
I'm not saying that you might not need one.
Maybe you're in Hawaii,
eh,
but you were being in Hawaii just for the deck,
but maybe you're in shy town and you need to be in Michigan somewhere.
Dang.
Nonetheless.
Go in there.
If he like something,
get something good way to support also psychological warfare on your campaign
against weakness.
That's where we're going with right now.
Campaign against weakness.
Improving yourself.
You're going from a person who with,
who is incapable of detaching,
who is incapable of understanding the message rather than your feeling about the
message.
You're,
if you're that person,
yet you're on the path to become a different person.
Someone who can understand the message first,
feeling second,
the ability to detach.
We're always working on and if you're working on that as well,
this is what you do.
You hit those moments of weakness.
You have this album with tracks.
Jocko track's called psychological warfare.
What it does is it takes any little element of your campaigning.
It's weakness.
Any little element that you might slip on the,
you might see that I sounded like you were at Thursday.
That might slip on it.
Oh,
may feel a little weak
when you wake up or when you're about to wake up,
when you're about to get up,
when you wake up,
you're about to get up.
It's four 30 and you're like,
Dang,
I'm going to press the snooze dory.
There's a track for that.
You play that track.
Jocko,
give you pragmatic advice on why you hit this news.
Same thing goes for skipping your workout.
Same thing goes for skimping on your diet,
slipping on your day.
Um,
creative,
blah,
procrastinate.
All these things is like tracks for where Jack was telling you why you shouldn't
do that.
It's like,
Hey,
don't do that.
You know,
this is why this is why it's beneficial for you to continue.
All that stuff.
It's a good one.
It helps hundred percent effective in spotting people when they need a little
spot.
If then if you need a spot,
sometimes you don't need a spot.
Sometimes you just get an afternoon,
hundred percent,
but that's a good one for that.
You also on Amazon can get Jocko white tea,
which is good.
If you don't believe me,
go read the reviews on there are read some of them.
I've,
again,
I read a couple of them on here,
but you can read them yourself.
The reviews.
Explain that when you drink Jocko white tea,
you can deadlift 8,000 pounds at a minimum.
So that's a guarantee.
People don't understand guaranteed.
If you don't think,
if you can't,
I'll give you your money back to the team.
Uh,
also got some books.
You can get them anywhere.
Really weigh the warrior kid.
Thank you everyone.
It gives me feedback all the time.
Kids that are doing various things like studying,
like reading the book,
studying,
doing Jujitsu,
doing pull ups,
swimming,
competing,
just all kinds of awesome stuff.
Everything from figure skating.
It's a ballet to wrestling scene at all.
Little warrior kids getting after it.
That's a book for any kid that you want to put on the proper path
of discipline of hard work.
The next book,
the next Warrior Kid book is coming out April 28th I'll let you know when it
pops up for preorder
extreme ownership.
The new edition is out.
It's longer.
It has a little new forward in it.
It's got some new pictures,
color pictures by the way.
Color stepping it up.
No,
I don't like that.
I was like,
no.
Make them black and white.
Black and white only.
That's how I roll.
There's also some Q and a on there.
Witches,
the Q and a that's in the new version is from this podcast,
which means it's from you listeners,
so thank you for the questions and also the new version.
It's black
and it's flat black.
Did you notice that?
Flat Black?
Yeah.
That makes it even better than just regular black.
Well,
what's the regular black glossy.
Oh,
glossy.
You hear that dog barking?
Yeah.
There must be somebody invading the podcast space.
Uh,
yeah.
You can get the new version of extreme ownership right now.
Flat black questions from the podcast,
all that.
Also
discipline equals freedom field manual.
So,
um,
this book is not a normal book,
right?
We know that it's a book that when you,
if you give it to somebody,
they don't feel like all,
he just went to grab me a book.
They don't feel like that Dang cause it's not normal.
So the publisher knows that.
Right.
So they wanted a little tagline and they sent me some,
hey we come up with some taglines and they gave me this tagline.
Sure.
Can I make fun of my publisher?
Yes.
Sounds like I'm going to do that right now.
So my publisher,
they say we got to make a little tag line.
You can tell your buck.
And they said well you know,
here's our tagline.
This book makes it makes a great gift for the holiday season.
Something like that.
Right.
And they send me,
cause cause I always say like,
hey don't be saying stuff about my stuff without asking me first.
Cause you guys will say dumb stuff about my cool stuff.
And I'm like that.
So they said this book makes a great holiday gift or whatever,
and I said,
no,
we,
I thought about it for four seconds and I wrote them back and I said,
use this.
There is no better gift than the gift of discipline.
Boom.
Factually,
there's your tagline.
So for your people in your life that you don't want to get them a stupid gift
like a neck tie or a belt or something else that they don't want or need.
They need this book.
The best gift you can give the gift of discipline.
So there you go.
That's a hey by the way,
people keep asking me and I keep telling everyone,
everyone wants the audio version of this book and they say,
when is it coming out?
It's out.
The audio version of discipline equals freedom field manual.
It's outright now it's on iTunes,
it's on Amazon music.
It's on Google play.
It's on all the MP three platforms.
The reason we did that is because of you got put it on all the bull,
all the bull.
You can't pull it out as tracks and use it for alarm or use it to spot yourself.
If you get a moment of weakness,
which this book is good for,
so that's where you can get the audio version of beyond the books beyond the
podcast for leadership training and execution with your business or your team,
you can contact our leadership consulting company.
It's me,
it's Leif Babin.
It's JP to know it's Dave Burke.
You can email info@echelonfront.com and if you have questions for us or you have
answers for us,
we want to hear them both.
You can communicate with us on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram and on Facebook.
Echo is an echo.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink and to the service men and women are world
ride right now,
defending for yum.
Thank you for your service and for giving us the ability to do this podcast and
to the families of those service men and women that are supporting them from
home.
Thank you for your sacrifice day to day.
It is much appreciated.
And to the police,
law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
other first responders.
Thank you for doing what you're doing,
which is keeping us safe here at home and answering the call when it comes.
And to everyone else that's listening,
just remember that.
Sure,
you have a team,
you have friends and family and coworkers and colleagues,
and you have a support network and you have people you can call and that's
great,
but don't count on them.
Don't wait for them.
Don't assume that they are coming to the rescue.
Okay?
Take lead,
take ownership,
take action.
Get out there
and get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.